at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
well hey you guys look we're both in the
frame today let's see how far off
Tom's not not in the next video I mean
you're in this video today thank you
that's good I'm glad you chose to join
us in this video got the damn Command
Center set up here yeah the command
center control room got the booze got
the tablet got a table yeah I mean
that's pretty much it we don't need a
lot of stuff I think I can go over here
and still be in okay yeah okay I mean
your head's kind of out all right I'm
gonna just move the control panels
closer all right sorry I was laughing at
murder Hornets Comet who said I'd let
Patty her shoot me she's still hot I
haven't seen a picture of her in a long
time she's got me she's got to be older
my mom uh she's 60. she's in her 60s I
guess late 60s maybe early 70s okay
I mean I don't know when the picture I
saw of her was but it looked fairly
recent so you know she still looks uh
she still looks maybe she's gonna be
watching
no well I'm gonna say like okay
um I watched a bunch of different
documentaries about this there's
actually like a really good one on
YouTube which is called gorilla and it's
about an hour and a half long and that
one's really good and then there's like
a couple other ones that like other
YouTubers have done and I don't know
like I've read a lot of stuff from both
sides because I know there's like you
know if you weren't around in the 70s
this was like a big [__] deal like
this case I was just a little kid in the
70s but man I even remember hearing
about this
um you know like a few years later and
they're still to this day I mean I don't
think anyone will ever know I mean
except her maybe
but there's still a lot of controversy
over
whether she
um was basically forced into doing what
she did
or if she did it voluntarily and then
later when she got caught tried to make
it seem like she was forced and she was
well
and she was from a rich family very rich
yeah
did she join this outfit
and then when they got busted talk her
way out of it oh they abducted me and
brainwashed me or was she brainwashed it
wasn't just forced
the story that she tells constitutes
brainwashing because she was with I
don't know if you guys know this but it
wasn't just like the bank robbery and
all that stuff she was with them for
like two years yeah almost or like 18
months or something like that like
before they caught her and it's like she
had and this was something that they
used a lot at her trial was that you
know she had ample opportunities to
leave to escape
um you know she had a lot of opportunity
to do that and she never did yeah and
the fact that she sent all these
communiques like to her parents like
denouncing them and calling them pigs
and all this other kind of stuff
um they're kind of like I mean okay I
don't want to like [__] so much on
brainwashing and Stockholm syndrome and
stuff like that because we'll get into
all that stuff before and the weird
thing about it is that one of her
supporters actually I guess sort of was
John Wayne because he came out like
especially after the um the whole
Jonestown thing happened and he's like
oh well why do people find it so hard to
believe that this one group had
brainwashed this 19 year old girl when
everybody believed that Jim Jones had
brainwashed 900 odd people into killing
themselves which is a good point really
the Duke is saying right okay yeah the
good audiobook
on YouTube that you can watch came out
in the 50s I'm listening to it I'm about
three quarters away through it it's
called rape of the mind and it's a book
about brainwashing and how it works how
the Nazis used it and how the Communists
used it and communist Chinese the
Russians and yeah it tells you the
symptoms how it's done
the mechanisms by which you do it
why it works and how long does it work
and if you brainwash a person you're
basically using guilt you're using their
own guilt and their own self-doubt
against them and you have you have to do
a bunch of other stuff to them you got
to dehumanize them it's basically
torture uh and then you you break them
down to nothing and you slowly kind of
build them back up and make them see the
world as you see it or it has you see
the world as maybe you want them to see
it and as long as they're under in your
direct sphere
and you can keep them guilty for their
the crimes that you've commenced
convinced them that they've done you can
keep them under control
you can get them to do things which may
have been the case here right or like I
said there could be a thing where
Stockholm syndrome where she did
genuinely start to sympathize with her
captors which is sort of the same thing
but not exactly the same thing yeah
although
um Stockholm syndra talks about it in in
the book all the data suggests that
women fall
fall to Stockholm syndrome faster than
men
and uh it's some kind of evolutionary uh
adaptation in women probably from a time
when in tribal times where you're with
your wife and your husband and your kids
a new group of men come in they kill
your husband and your kids
maybe they keep some of the female
children alive and then you get handed
over to one of the conquerors
um then all of us you know it's that's
it's called trauma-based mind control
that's a traumatic event
but then you start seeing
seeing it Through The Eyes of the
attacker like well my husband couldn't
protect me he was weaker than these than
this group here
and the the boys that they killed would
have been weak like my husband
daughters that I have will marry the new
strong males
and I'll bond with them that's the same
thing that happens in the animal kingdom
with dab lions and
primates and [__]
so I don't think it's a human adaptation
I think it's just from the Animal
Kingdom
now it wouldn't work in the modern world
today when there's so many choices but
in medieval times or tribal times that
would be a way a woman could survive it
okay it's like like a survival
adaptation well that's the mechanism by
which brainwashing and trauma-based mind
control
that's how it works you [__] the person
up kind of like erasing them through
trauma
you give them a new set of rules
and uh you slowly bring them out of the
shell you use a bunch of guilt against
them so they attack themselves
and then you give them a promise of
Salvation if they join a new cause with
you and then you start affirming them
and then if it's like you're dealing
with a new person but it
history and the study showed over and
over again it doesn't last that long as
soon as you can get that person back out
of that situation like captivity and get
them back into the environment they came
from it'll reverse itself over time uh
you know weeks or months like the guys
that got uh uh captured and tortured by
the uh North Vietnamese like the pilots
and [__] they would do that they would
denounce the United States and do I like
the guy who blinked torture through his
you know yeah that kind of stuff some
dudes could some dudes could resist it
longer than others but uh yeah I mean
everybody's different yeah but if you if
you listen to the the audiobook rape of
the mind it's big it's long it's in
little sections you see that basically
everyone will break eventually well yeah
everyone will break them it's just when
and uh
then the methods by which to get a
person to break easy easier they noticed
that in the Soviet Union you had [__]
tough ass Bolshevik revolutionaries when
Stalin's guys started to erase the
revolutionaries that brought him into
power they were tough you couldn't
torture them into any confessions so
what you did was they had a law in in
Old Soviet Russia that they could give a
death penalty to like a 13 year old
so they would come in with death
warrants for their children
in under just trumped up crimes and
they'll do it would fold instantly and
just say anything
a lot of guys are willing to die for
what they believe in almost nobody's
willing to let their family die from
what they believe in that's the that's
the key that's how North Korea does what
they do
that's why if you want to be a true
revolutionary or true extremist you
can't have any women or children you've
got to just be a [__] Kamikaze that
way they can't use that against you
yeah I mean because they will and like
you said that's pretty much the most
effective way of doing that yep but the
um what I was gonna say uh about uh what
was I talking about um about well
whether or not she was brainwashed no no
about Stockholm syndrome was I was
watching something with uh with Dr
Grande uh earlier he was like a YouTube
he's a psychiatrist and he's on YouTube
and he does like a lot of funny like
videos they're kind of funny but you
know I mean they're serious too and he
did one about Patty Hearst and he was
talking about Stockholm syndrome and he
said something really interesting that I
didn't I guess this never really
occurred to me but he's like Stockholm
syndrome it's not recognized in the DSM
uh he's like technically it's not even
really A syndrome like in the clinical
uh definition of the word
um he's like but the interesting thing
about it and I'm paraphrasing like what
he was saying but he's like really
Stockholm syndrome is so common uh among
people that are abducted and things like
that that it's really not even
considered pathological it's just kind
of consider are like pretty much a
normal reaction to that situation yeah
bolster is what I said about it yeah
because people especially women they
have some kind of a packet to where the
women that survived capture even back in
pre-human times were ones that could
adapt to the capture that's what kept
them alive so we inherited those genes
didn't seem to be a priority with men
because men were just killed
you know
and uh although I think some men did
have things like Stockholm syndrome or
something similar to it when they were
captured but I don't think it was as
strong I mean some women were known to
actually like mate and have children
with with the captors you know there's a
lot of that with the serial killers and
[__] that girl that kept in a box for
years was in love with the dude that
would had captured it as a weird [__]
the mind I mean yeah your brain does
weird [__] under those kinds of
conditions right so just because you
think it's wrong doesn't mean it's true
it isn't true it is true the the human
mind is uh very malleable it just tries
to survive it'll survive any way it can
and if mating with the attacker is your
only way of surviving they'll do it
you know it's not conscious it's just
instinctive I guess
but that was how our ancestors survived
a brutal [__] climb through [__]
Evolution you know
and some people are talking about the
movies too um and I wanted to get a
little bit into because I don't know if
you guys know because I'm a big John
Waters fan and John Waters has actually
put the real Patricia Hurst in five of
his movies uh she was in Serial Mom she
was in Cecil B demented which is
actually a great movie and actually very
Loosely based on the Patty Hearst
kidnapping case
um it's a little bit different it's a
comedy obviously uh but yeah Dirty Shame
she was in that one as well but yeah she
was in a bunch of his uh movies so I
thought that was kind of interesting
like I guess they were friends or
whatnot
um but yeah I don't know I guess there
have been like other maybe serious
movies made about this but I've only
seen the John Waters ones I hate to say
but like I said there is like a good
documentary that I watched earlier today
that's called gorilla that's about
that's you know
non-fiction that's about this case so
before we get too much into this Ben
frail is here
and I just got a package yesterday in
the mail all the way from Australia and
he has sent me this book here which
looks awesome so this is like a true
crime book
the old the stuccos yeah
shipping from Australia is a [__] arm
and a leg right and I'm just like damn
it's like that's really awesome and
you're right I had never heard of this
case and I try to keep up one because I
wrote about like a bunch of Australian
cases and stuff like that like in my
book but I had actually never heard
about this one so I'm really looking
forward to reading this and maybe we'll
do a show about it one of these days
like after I finish reading it
shouldn't take me too long I read pretty
fast but yeah thank you very much for
sending that like I said I know it's
very expensive to like shift stuff I
mean I don't know it's it's expensive to
ship stuff to Australia that's for sure
I'm not really sure how expensive it is
to ship from there but uh yeah although
the weird thing about it is that
sometimes like when I would go and ship
stuff to like the UK and Australia
sometimes they'd be almost the same
price which is weird because you'd think
it's like so much farther but I don't
know I don't know how they work it out
um yeah mr88 said Stockholm syndrome is
just a specific survival adaptation yeah
I just really I liked the way that Dr
Grande put it like I said I don't
remember the exact words he used so I'm
like paraphrasing but he's basically
saying it's like it's not
technically it's not a mental disorder
it's just like what most people would do
in that situation to keep their eyes
alive you know what I mean so it's not
it's not pathological like I said which
is why it's not performance it's not
which is why it's not considered a
mental disorder but the thing about it
was that when uh Patricia Hurst was put
on trial for the crimes which we'll get
into shortly
um they did actually try to argue that
she was brainwashed or something like
that and that was really
they didn't understand it as well in the
1970s as they maybe I don't think they
understand it like super well now but
for real not then and nobody had ever
used that as a defense before
brainwashing right
um because it would have been real the
United States wouldn't have been real
familiar with it that's what I'm saying
it wasn't yeah it wasn't really
understood and they said basically the
the legal precedent for being coerced
into something was you basically had to
feel that your life was in danger right
now
um you know somebody was holding a gun
to your head making you rob the store or
whatever
um they didn't really have any
parameters for talking about somebody
that maybe had been uh you know kept
prisoner and like I said kind of slowly
brainwashed and is maybe looking like
they're doing this of their own volition
because that's what it looked like when
the tapes came out which we'll talk
about in a minute but um you know it's
just funny that if you if you read that
book or listen to that book rape of the
Mind you'll see that brainwashing is
there's a is a is a European thing all
right the Chinese picked it up from from
the Russian Communists but it's a
European tactic
and it's and it's a form of government
in a certain way totalitarian
governments always use brainwashing you
start with brainwashing through the mass
media
to force consensus to to force people to
see the the world situation through a
certain lens and then you only use
information Warfare to
make them believe things that aren't
true
the the Nazi empire did it so the Soviet
Union and the United States does it it's
just different the way it looks they do
it through Hollywood which is
subcontracted out by the federal
government basically there's all kinds
of government [__] in there and it's
been that way since World War II
all right nothing new all right
so huh no just just trying to give a
little bit of background brainwashing is
a reality very much yeah I'm not saying
that you know I'm not saying it doesn't
exist I'm just saying that we don't
really know what the specific case was
going on with which like I said I'm I
don't really have a dog in this fight
um I don't know the woman it's like I
don't really
like I said I kind of read like some
sources on either side of the thing like
I listened to like the FBI guys that
were like hunting her I listened to
surviving members of the SLA that were
interviewed like in some documentaries
and stuff and like their take on it and
so you know
um so I'm not really sure where I come
down on it like it's I don't know it
could be like a lot more complicated
than I'm giving it credit for I don't
think that I would go so far as to say
like she joined voluntarily because me
and Tom were talking like right before
the stream started that Tom was like
well do you think that maybe she could
have known them ahead of time and just
like the kidnapping was staged yeah and
I was like I'm not really sure I'd go
that far I did see a couple of sources
that speculated that maybe she had known
those guys previous to the abduction
um but I don't know if that's the case
how they know where she was
um they knew where she was because one
of the members worked at the bookstore
at Berkeley where she was going to
school and they found her and everybody
knew that she was going there because
she was a Hearst and she was kind of
famous so they found her address in the
uh registrar's okay the records so okay
so everybody knew that she went there
okay so that's plausible you know
because uh it's very unlikely that a
group would abduct such a high profile
person that's a ballsy move because you
know that if you were in charge of that
group that the whole world was going to
come after you
well that's what they wanted
um which we'll get into in a bit but
like they had motives for kidnapping her
not her specifically but somebody of her
stature and she was just the one that
they knew was available to them you know
I mean because they knew where she was
and she was female which is easier you
can Ruff rub around and Intimidator yeah
and she was just I mean she's just
really a kid she was 19 years old when
she got abducted yeah so you know I mean
I'm sure she's gonna do whatever you say
once you get her pretty much yeah yeah
uh murder Hornet said they went out in a
blaze of glory literally they did uh
they did which we'll get into in a bit
um and like I said this group it's funny
because I feel like it's kind of weird
to say this but you know obviously it's
super shitty what they did it's terrible
but in a way it kind of got them what
they wanted because you this is a tiny
tiny group what is like 12 people Max
like that's all it was and everybody
still remembers them nowadays when like
a lot of other groups from that era have
probably been forgotten and the reason
that they remember them is because of
the [__] that they pulled yeah yeah it's
a waste of time really those old well
they didn't get anything they wanted
really yeah the era of direct action was
over by that time you
well I understand back in those days
they didn't have a social media they
didn't have any way to get messages out
so you had to do something high profile
to get your message out yeah and they
thought that if the message was out that
they would like spark a big revolution
yeah they were trying to that's very
much wishful thinking I mean that's
projection I mean they were very young
right I mean they were all they were
they were only in their 20s they were
very idealistic uh and took things way
way way too far clearly a lot of that
stuff came from like Marxist writings
that were from Europe in the [__] 20s
and 30s and 40s yeah you could overthrow
a country in Europe back in those days
by using [__] like that those countries
were [__] tiny they were the size of
[__] couple big counties here in the
United States but the size of the United
States divided by States each state you
know Union no you're never going to have
a [__] Nationwide Rebellion or
revolution the numbers aren't there
either
of who they wanted to rise up there the
numbers just aren't there
and um then you can say well it didn't
take very many Bolsheviks to overthrow
the Soviet Union yeah it didn't take
very many Bolsheviks to overthrow the
Soviet Union because all the Rail lines
went through Moscow if you had if you
had control over that central train
station there you could control the
entire country because you could
choke off supplies or send [__]
troops or stop troops from coming
because you controlled the central train
Depot
well they never have in America man is
[__] vast Road systems and no you
can't well especially like take anything
to control anything here it's like
grabbing air or water it's just well
it's just everything's just too like
yeah diffused diffused everything is
these kind of things will never work
that's why they use information Warfare
you just do [__] with your information
flow over the internet
if you can have good Traction in the
internet you can get anything you want
these guys would have done a lot better
in the internet age yeah but you know
they didn't have it they didn't have
that back then yeah you kind of had to
do stupid [__] a little bit you had to
do stupid [__] yourself right and you
get killed and then you're silenced
after you're dead
better if you just have a YouTube
channel you could talk for [__] years
because spoiler alert uh half of them
did get killed yeah and the other half
pretty much went to prison
um yeah and like I said there was really
only like 11 12 of them yeah like that
was all there was uh Ben says and I've
heard this uh as well I don't know how
if this is the case but I have heard
this Theory also that Donald defreeze
who we're gonna get into in a minute who
was a member
um some say the leader although some of
the other members that they had
interviewed were like we didn't really
have a leader per se but you know what I
mean
um Donald defreeze was an FBI informant
the whole time SLA part of cointelpro to
discredit the left maybe so uh I have
heard that he was an FBI informant but I
don't know if that's the case uh but
yeah we'll I didn't go too much of it I
did kind of go into like the background
of the SLA and Donald the freeze and
stuff like that I was mostly like
concentrating on Patty Hearst and the
kidnapping of that but I did kind of
like go into the background of that as
well yeah go and tell Pro they were
doing [__] like framing [__] innocent
black panthers instead of them to
[__] prison yeah yeah and because
don't so that's what UCLA was not the
[__] black panthers the Black Panther
the Black Panthers the Black Panthers
actually came out like against and we'll
talk about why that was because it's
some [__] up [__] that the SLA did
prior to the kidnapping that uh the
Black Panther and actually all the other
leftist groups around the time were like
yeah no yeah we're not with them the
original black panthers were a good
outfit you know they were just kind of
uh right they were constitutional that
was kind of like a a [__] civilian
militia which that's right there in the
Constitution that it was a self-defense
group you know and they were fighting
for their own rights don't mistake them
for the New Black Panther Party though
that's kind of like a cheap knockoff you
know what I mean not the same racist if
you ask me black panthers weren't racist
they were just trying to get along
trying to get their rights yeah because
that's all you know right and like I
said they had legit they had a legit
right yeah they did and well like I said
some of the [__] that the SLA said even
though they didn't really have I don't
know if I would call the SLA they didn't
really have like a real
I don't know like a real cohesive
ideology I would say they were obviously
like very anti-corporate very
anti-capitalism
um I've seen somebody call them
anarchists I don't know if I would say
that or not but they were very much like
for the rights of the oppressed and
everything like that but the way they
went about it was like stupid as [__]
yeah there's an old black panther I'll
listen to on YouTube and he he'll end up
on some of the some of the shows listen
to his think his name is Larry Pickney I
think his name was and cointelpro sent
him to prison you listen to him I think
it's Pickney pick me I think you guys
can correct me in the comment section
um that dude's on point man he he knows
exactly how this [__] system works
and the corruption and uh you know
special interest groups that
corporations own everything and make
everything happen they have no this
government's got nothing to do with us
and [__] help on us and I mean that's
what I mean so it's like some of the
[__] that the SLA said even though some
of it was like obviously like ridiculous
but some of the [__] they said I'm like
yeah okay like if you like most people
would agree with that probably but
that's the thing just because you agree
with a couple of things they said that
doesn't mean that you yeah endorse their
yeah methods yeah which were [__] up
right
do you know what I mean abducting and
raping people and [__] [__] well and
murdering and murdering people so there
was that too which I think maybe a lot
of people don't know like one of that
one of the things happened like I said
would that's why they had a beef with
the black panther party it's just you
know just just kind of dumb thinking
they they want to solve a problem with
Hands-On means and the problem could not
be solved with Hands-On means it's got
to be done through information Warfare
they should have just pulled their money
together and bought a radio station that
would have done a lot more damage sit
there just probably like I said
information is a lot more powerful if
you honestly any kind of group and even
if you have like I said even if your
goals are something like good if you
have like good intentions it's never
ever it's always going to blow up in
your face if you try to start doing I'm
not saying like anything illegal because
I'm not talking but anytime you like
hurt anybody or hurt innocent people
you're bombing [__] you're doing like I
said that's always gonna blow up in your
face yeah unless you want something to
blow up like uh you can spark Civil Wars
if you want that right but I'm usually
the person that's sparking The Civil
Wars and neither side they're trying to
get two in besides to fight each other
you know and then once once the winner
arises he'll be weak and then you can go
after that one so usually you start a
civil war to to weaken two enemies
that's usually how you do it yeah I'm
just saying that if you have goals along
the lines that the SLA did which some of
which were noble goals
um this is not the way to go about a pro
tip uh yeah because it didn't accomplish
anything and a bunch of innocent people
got killed so you know there was that
xanadas said I watched a three-hour
documentary and these guys did a lot of
research on them very unorganized group
in my opinion yeah they really didn't
have their [__] together uh to be honest
with you kind of aimless in their goals
but very interesting topic yeah I found
it very interesting as well but yeah
they were just kind of like I said they
weren't this big like you know organized
terrorist cell or anything like that it
was just like a bunch of
super idealistic college students pretty
much
um you know or it's not all of them were
college students some of them were like
had been like prisoners that escaped and
[__] like that but
um like I said and some of their goals
were quite Noble actually but they just
uh went way too [__] far and just the
[__] got ridiculous and people ended up
yesterday and he agreed with me right
there
that
yeah Mr 80 ironic the newspaper radio
station would have been the sla's best
play uh William Randolph Hearst
exploited that route better than yeah
that's true the highest form of
warfare's fifth generation Warfare which
involves information Warfare
all right that's one one facet of it
owning media
or or at least having because you have
to get a message out and if the message
is message is true
it goes viral it goes viral because
people in their heart know what what's
true just by yeah this is that that's
right that's the situation I'm seeing
you know and um if it was true if what
the SLA believed in was true if they
were able to get that message out
through the airwaves they would have got
a lot more traction than going out and
[__] using viables well they would
have gotten more a lot more sympathy
like I said that's a good thing
especially you know a group like the SLA
which like I said on its face had you
know what could be considered like noble
goals for like helping the oppressed and
things like that it's like a lot of
people would be on board with that
um if you didn't go around killing
random people and blowing [__] up and
building bombs and stuff like that you
would get a lot more sympathy to your
cause I'm just saying it just doesn't
it's just never the right way to go I'm
just you know other than it being
morally reprehensible it's also not
effective so you know what I mean like I
said unless Thomas aimless that's what
you want I mean but that was I don't
think that's what they wanted and
actually some of the SLA members later
on that you know didn't participate in
the abduction because they were in jail
for other things and [__] like that
um they were like you know people are
turning up dead and it's like that
wasn't really what we wanted that wasn't
what we intended but it just kind of
like went that way you know what I mean
um so yeah somebody was saying like the
60s and 70s were [__] up decades yeah
that's why I just kind of don't get
um all that upset about like you know
[__] that's going on now because I'm
just like I I was a little kid during
the 70s but I remember like some [__]
was [__] up okay that was just kind of
like all of the [__] riots all of the
[__] you know those Watergate Vietnam
it was just like [__] protest all the
time it was like [__] people forget
but it's like in the 70s [__] planes
were being hijacked by terrorists all
the time there was like [__] bombs
like I think like between 1972 1973 was
like 4 000 bombs yeah like playing it
around the United States it was just
like it was [__] crazy the crime was
real bad too the crime was horrible much
worse than it is now way worse people
yeah it was [__] up back then it was
uh but the thing is is that what they
were doing was dumb [__] that really
didn't make a big difference it just
caused [__] chaos
um what's happening now is a lot smarter
and a lot more dangerous yeah I mean
real high levels of information Warfare
you got people trying to start World War
Three with [__] Russia they're trying
to bring nuclear weapons he's just got a
lot of dumb [__] happening at very high
levels that that it's not as violent as
it was but it's a lot more
insidious insidious yeah
yeah they're trying to get they're
trying to control your opinions by
controlling what kind of information you
get and then there's a lot of gas
lighting and uh and really you should
follow the money it's going up into
corporations that are doing it uh and
they're doing it for [__] reasons
because they're kind of like merged in
with what what Ian Fleming called
Specter which is [__] gangs of evil
oligarchs you know and who've taken over
things like the U.N and all these
[__] International organizations is
just corruption has a lot to do with it
people trying to be more important than
they really are
uh but it's all a very dangerous
situation I think this is the end of an
era something new is going to come but
it can't this can't go on for long kind
of like the end of the Roman Empire
and what's funny is that the Roman
Empire ended but that really wasn't the
end because new nations were born out of
it you know the medieval period and
these Gothic Empires and [__] [__]
and a lot of good stuff came out of that
people realize that technology continued
to go decrease and certain things got
better we've talked about that before if
you were living back then on the ground
it wouldn't have seemed like because
because a lifetime is so short we only
see it in hindsight you only see it in
retrospect because you can see the long
span of history and you can see what
happens subsequently like what the
Fallout was like what the repercussions
were like at the time you were living
through it it probably wouldn't have
seemed like anything you know what I
mean it had been kind of like normal
after Rome fell apart there were people
in places that were no longer Rome
because they were considering themselves
Roman like the Visigoths considered
themselves be Roman from what I remember
um I think he's had some of the
symbols of Rome still
because they thought they were upholding
Roman values
Rome is long gone
you know there's like Charlemagne was
thinking that too but Rome was long gone
Mr 88 said the 70s were so violent
because people were pissed they had to
wear this awful clothes
I don't doubt it I'm sure that was a
factor murder Hornet said their
underground planted a lot of bombs but
didn't want to kill people they would
warn them before until one day they blew
themselves up making a bomb LOL yes they
did
um and also suggested that we do a show
on the Weather Underground which
probably should one of these days we
didn't do a show in the Weather
Underground
nah I thought we did but okay maybe not
70s were dumb because of all that leaded
gasoline
well we've talked about that we've
talked about maybe that's why there was
so much crime and serial killers and
[__] like that I'm sure that's a factor
like I said electric poisoning I'm sure
that's it I'm sure
violent and dumb yeah
it was it was a crazy time so like I
said it's you know
I I think people like piss and moan
about [__] nowadays but people always
piss and moan about oh I live in the
worst of times and it's like man
it wasn't like now isn't even if it's
not anything like the 70s ones the 70s
was way worse I feel like late 60s to
through the 70s I feel like it was a lot
more violent you don't see the same kind
of [__] they had some good food in the
70s though man pizza was [__] great
in the 70s
I don't know they had a lot of shitty
food too Round Table Pizza in [__]
California I will argue I would argue
that the 70s were probably the best
decade for filmmaking
uh and possibly music
um at least the late 70s but as far as
culture goes you could get a beautiful
steak in the 70s that's right you
probably still can nowadays if you pay
for it it's just the money yeah sure I
feel like I'm living in Soylent Green
now remember purchase Meredith remember
that strawberries strawberry what are
you talking about we eat good food all
the time I know I've never just saying
that man Tom's been making salads with
like all stuff we grew out in the
backyard and we need to get a steak
though man I haven't had a steak in a
long time I know I want a nice [__]
Blue Steak I want a [__] rare ass
[__] I can do it I haven't seen
that in a long time I'm getting ready to
[__] lay out 60 70 bucks instead how
about that like big old [__] steaks
cook it on the grill out there yeah I
rebuilt the grill
every now and I haven't had a steak in a
long time every now and then I want to
rip but when if you if I have a steak I
want it [__] rare man and I'm not
kidding okay because sometimes I go to
like a steak restaurant and I'm just
like I want it rare and then it's like
Yeah medium rare I'm like good I want it
[__] bloody you know what I'm saying
I like it like that I kind of like
burgers like that too I know a lot of
people are grossed out by that
but you know what are you gonna do
the Heart Wants What It Wants as does
the stomach
um and yeah so yeah so another thing in
the 70s too is like that [__] oil
crisis remember like all this [__]
people you'd see those huge lines of
people like trying to get gas and like
the gas would run out there'd be signs
all over the gas stations no gas today
and all that other kind of [__] it was a
it was a [__] show pretty much it was a
[__] show so you Mr 88 recognizes he's
seen right there recognize Tom Round
Table Pizza in Canyon County California
was my favorite
place to eat when I was in elementary
school that's right that round table was
the [__] and it happened it had Missile
Command in there and they'd have Battle
Zone
and centipede
yeah centipede was one of my favorite
yeah video games back in the day
I used to be pretty good brand with a
big ball and Battle Zone where they were
[__] with the tank game yeah yeah
yeah instead of talking about the
Weather Underground how they it's like I
think they filled killed a few cleaners
or night Watchmen but they didn't try to
have casualties it's more about property
damage than spreading Terror yeah I mean
they did I mean that's still shitty it's
like you know because even if you
accidentally kill a person that person's
still dead you know what I mean but I
mean I guess it does mean something that
they didn't really intend to kill
anybody but yeah so what yeah so what I
was saying like is so into this kind of
whole
1970s which was this [__] show like I
said
um so there was a lot of this kind of
[__] going on
so
this is what happens this happened in
February of 1974.
this is actually the first time that
somebody as famous as high profile as
Patricia Hurst was actually like
abducted now if you don't know who
Patricia Hurst is I'm sure most people
do know but she is actually the
granddaughter of William Randolph Hearst
the publishing magnate who fun fact was
the inspiration for Orson Welles classic
Citizen Kane that's who that was about
so uh Patricia Hurst came from like a
very very wealthy family maybe not I
mean
really I mean they're rich as [__] okay
so I'm not saying this to like kind of
mitigate that in any way but maybe not
as rich as you might be thinking because
I guess William Randolph Hearst he had
five kids and he gave each of them like
a big chunk of the fortune but then like
most of the fortune he had like tied up
in this trust or his company or
something like that so they were super
wealthy and super influential but maybe
didn't have like you know quite as much
money falling out of their [__] but
I'm just saying obviously like super
super wealthy super privileged so there
was that
so in 1974 Patricia Hurst was 19 years
old and she was going to uh University
of California Berkeley she was um you
know she was a sophomore I believe and
she was studying uh art history
now what happened with this whole thing
was that as I mentioned earlier
um the reason that the SLA targeted her
specifically like I said they were just
looking for somebody that was kind of
like high profile that would kind of
like represent
um you know the capitalist class that
they were trying to you know
they were that they were trying to
highlight and so it just so happened
that I believe one of the members of the
SLA either worked at the bookstore at
Berkeley or knew somebody that worked
there and they said it was kind of open
you know it was everybody knew that uh
Patty Hearst was going to Berkeley and
so they said it was pretty easy to like
find out where she lived now as I said I
have seen some sources that said that
um that Patty Hearst knew a couple
members of the SLA prior to her
abduction but I don't know if that's the
case I have heard from one particular
source that I read that said that she
had actually visited Donald defreeze who
you know later would go on to be could
the quote unquote like ursat's leader of
it
um that she had visited him in prison
like prior to his escape again I don't
know if that's the case or not or
probably whatever after after
her abduction by him
no no no
um he escaped prior to the abduction
okay but there I'm just saying that
there had been some speculation at least
that she had met him prior to his escape
from prison
I don't know if that's true or not like
I really only found like one source that
said that so I don't really know if
that's true sounds flimsy yeah so yeah
I'm just I'm just mentioning it I'm just
not saying it's true or not but I'm just
saying yeah
so
here so okay
so this group The SLA
um they decide well Patty hears she's
like a perfect Target right she's very
very she's from a very wealthy family
she's a very prominent family and they
figured
that what they were initially planning
to do was that they were going to kidnap
her and they were going to use her as a
like a prisoner exchange because two of
their members had been uh put in jail
for a murder which I'll talk about uh in
a little while so they were gonna do
they're like hey you know if you let
those two guys out we'll give you your
daughter back that was their initial
plan that's not really how it worked out
but that's what they were planning on
doing
so
let's talk a little bit about this group
though so we've talked a little bit
about them before SLA The symbianese
Liberation Army symbionese doesn't
really I mean it's not a real word they
just like made it up and I guess what
they were getting at was that it was
kind of a play on symbiosis they were
trying to maybe
um kind of get together all these
disparate sort of groups that had
similar goals and kind of like get them
all under one
umbrella I guess is what they were
shooting for uh but you know spoiler
alert that's not really how it worked so
yeah like I said there was just like 11
12 people pretty much
now they were actually founded in 1973
by the aforementioned Donald defreeze
now he took the name a bunch of them
changed their names
um you know when they joined the group
which very culty always watch if
somebody's asking you to do that [__]
but um yeah so Donald defreeze uh you
know founded the group in 1973. and his
name was General Field Marshal Cinque
Cinque I think is what they call the
sinque or something like that
um so basically they were kind of like
it started out
as like I said they started out with the
sort of noble goal of their whole thing
was that they
saw black prisoners as essentially like
prisoners of War because like the
government was imprisoning them for
[__] charges or like you know if
they were innocent and things like that
which like I said
there is a little bit of Truth in that
particularly in the 1970s
um but you know I think they got to a
point where they're just saying like
well all black people in prison are all
prisoners of War like they're all you
know what I mean it actually got worse
with what they called the multi-bill or
the three strikes you're out bill yeah
where if you just had three
convictions you get life no matter how
small those convictions were yeah that
could be that was I didn't make any
[__] sense and guess who is the big
supporter of that one if I can Joe Biden
all right go figure but you can go back
and look at it he was one more well like
I said that was that was kind of made me
mad because like I said I'm a Democrat
I'm a liberal stuff like that but that
was one of the things that pissed me off
is that they were trying to make
themselves seem like tough on crime and
I'm like why the [__] like why would you
do like such a stupid stupid law that is
I'm like that is gonna blow up in your
face I'm a political atheist uh
it's just Coke and Pepsi it's still just
Cola they don't work for us they work
for corporate overlords and oligarchs
they're going to do whatever they want
to do you're just going to vote for one
part of the other and they own them both
there are some people in there that are
[__] rocking the boat but it's all
just
show it's a show for you because you're
plebs your plebs peasants you know
they're just making you feel like you
have some kind of say in this or some
kind of choice it's a fake democracy
it's just window dressing they own the
system so that's what they wanted if if
the Democrats didn't support that the
Republicans would have or they just
would have done it together it's the
same [__] they did on the war against
[__] drugs because there's a lot of
money to be made in that it just it's
money they're all bribed
Kickbacks they go into those [__]
offices broke
they're they're in their 30 years and
they come out in their
multi-multi-millionaires
and they didn't make that much money
where'd all that money come from yeah
come on
only a child would believe
but uh
yeah multi-bill that one so that's a
that was a great they got rid of that
they should have never had that Mr 88
said didn't have to be three felonies
yeah it had to be I thought it had to be
three felonies yeah had to be three
still though but some of those felonies
though were not it didn't have to be a
violent felony I don't think that's what
I mean there's a felony I mean that's
there there's a lot of stuff here in the
US it's a felony you're like kind of a
[__] you're like wait a minute hold
on what yeah like I might go along with
it if it was like three like violent
crimes that might okay maybe but it's
like even then I don't really like those
kind of
one-size-fits all kind of solutions for
[__] because there's always like
mitigating circumstances you kind of
have to take everything like on a
case-by-case another thing they did is
like in the 50s and 60s they really
started to ratchet down
on the concept of a failure
if you took a felony it was on your
record forever you really couldn't
rejoin Society with full rights and some
of those dudes lost their voting rights
gun rights whatever
so they they made a huge marginalized
criminal classes I mean does that seems
like really obvious and so then they
become repeat offenders right because
what else are you gonna do snowballs and
snowballs that's totally
unconstitutional totally stupid if you
commit a crime you go to prison you pay
for it you lose your rights when you're
in prison
when the sentence is served your rights
are restored you're now a citizen again
you've paid for it you should have full
Rights Voting Rights gun rights you're a
human yeah they suggest humans have
human rights that's what the
Constitution is if they don't think that
you should be allowed out then don't let
you out if they're say well he's too
dangerous to have the rights of a
citizen don't let him out
if you let him out and he served his
sentence then that's what he should have
because you're like you said you're just
that shit's just blowing up in your face
because you're making an underclass
these people can't get jobs they can't
vote they can't do this and that they
can't participate in yeah the community
anymore and it's like that's just
pushing them back toward the same
[__] [__] again in the traditional
it's better for society as a whole in
the traditional American culture back in
the 1800s even when the ship was going
strong a dude would go to jail or prison
maybe for robbery
and do five ten years locked up get out
and become a cop
yeah and be a good cop
because he he's like I've had to catch
criminals you pay me I'll catch
criminals I used to be a criminal you
know that was very common a lot of them
didn't change their names just became
somebody else well that was easy to do
so it was a law man the law man of the
old America who played both sides but
the sheriff knew who was men where some
of them were straight up some of them
might be a little and if you were real
kind of sideways you became a Pinkerton
which was like a
that's what the FBI was modeled after
that was another show that we I don't
remember I don't remember if I ever
wrote it down I think I put it in the
poll a couple times but it didn't win
but I don't remember if I put it Baker
tins pinkertons were the original snake
pliskins they would hire any Talent they
didn't care as long as you could get the
job done they had [__] ex-criminals
in there ex-cops X hookers
because they used female sex operatives
too they were [__] very Advanced they
wrote the book on it
on Special Operations the [__]
Pinkerton detective agency
um okay so yeah so the SLA initially
started out as like this kind of like a
convicts Rights group or like I said
they were kind of like trying to draw
attention to the fact that a lot of uh
black men particularly were in prison
for perhaps [__] charges or perhaps
if they were innocent or were railroaded
in jail or whatever which like I said
does happen so that wasn't crazy
um now initially
Donald defreeze was in spite of the
group's first initial goals was the only
black member the only the other seven
members were white
um but you know what I mean but they did
all take on uh Swahili names for
whatever reason and uh you know started
training with guns and everything like
that and they also had a motto they had
a logo too uh which is like a
seven-headed cobra type of thing uh
which you can see on the flag that's
behind Patty Hearst and the very famous
photo of her in the Beret uh but they
had a motto also which was death to the
fascist insect that preys upon the life
of the people and they repeated that
like all the time
so um now remember when I said that when
they abducted Patty Hearst initial their
initial plan was they were going to
trade her for two of their members that
had been arrested
the thing that the two members had been
arrested for was an assassination so
there's that
this actually happened in November of
1973.
now two of the members or at least you
know the two guys that I don't know how
many of them were involved in planning
it but two guys like eventually ended up
going to prison for it
but they assassinated this guy named
Marcus Foster Marcus Foster
interestingly was the first black
superintendent of schools in Oakland
California
the reason that Donald defreeze targeted
him another black man which he would
think was not really in line with the
group's goals at least you know going
forward
he thought and the other people in the
group thought that because
he was gonna do
um the plan that he was gonna put into
action they I don't know if this was the
case or not but they understood it to
mean that he was advocating for uh
mandatory ID cards they did not like
that thinking that was like a fascist
rule so they decided that they were
going to kill him over it which seems a
little excessive
so uh they actually did they shot him
and they shot another uh guy too who was
with him who was wounded
now because of this assassination uh
again the Black Panther Party were like
bro
we don't want any part of that
um and a lot of other leftist groups who
maybe would have been sympathetic to
their cause otherwise after this
happened we're like yeah no we're not
hanging with you guys so uh so there was
that
so uh two of the guys uh got arrested
for this murder their names were Russell
little and Joseph Romero
now after these two went to prison that
was when they started thinking well we
need to abduct somebody to get these two
[__] out of jail even though
they killed somebody so you know
whatever
so what they decided to do was because
Patty Hearst went to Berkeley and they
knew where she lived and she was very
prominent from a very wealthy family
they decided we're going to abduct her
and trade her for them
so in February of 1974
five of the members put on masks and
essentially broken her apartment now
I've heard I don't know if they kicked
in the door I think what they did was
they had one of the female members go up
to the door and say hey I need your
phone there's an accident or some [__]
like that and then when either Patty or
her boyfriend whose name was Stephen
weed
um when they when one of them went to
the door they kicked it in and they all
had guns and they like beat the [__] out
of her boyfriend and basically picked
her up in bodily put a blindfold on her
and carried her out and like stuck her
in the trunk of their car
um interestingly she had been her
boyfriend Stephen weed
um this is really weird I was reading
One Source that said that he was 51
years old and she was 19. I'm like
that's
not the case I'm pretty sure he was 26.
I think people got upset because he was
a he was her teacher like I think he
taught music or something like that and
she took a class from him and I think
there was like some kind of controversy
because she was like dating a teacher
but I'm like look he was legit like only
six or seven years older than her so
yeah there's University that's what I
mean that's what they can do that not
really that big a deal it's just weird
because I was like what I was reading
this one breakdown I'm like he was not
51 and he was 26 years old yeah like
there's even like news footage of him
from the time where he's talking about
the kidnapping like and I'm like he's
obviously just obviously young guy yeah
yeah so there was that but yeah he got
uh beat up as far as I know and they
basically destroy he he said initially
that he thought it was a robbery because
he said that's what they said when they
busted in like he tied them up and he's
just like where's the money where's the
money like all that kind of stuff and
he's like and I could hear Patricia like
kind of whimpering in the other room and
he didn't really know what was going on
in there
and then he saw them like carry her out
you know what I mean I'm tying her up
right yeah and she and like I said she
had a blindfold on and they sucker I
think they put her in the trunk of the
car and like drove off with her
so three days after that
um the SLA
set a letter to the media and whatnot
and they basically said Patty Hearst is
a prisoner of war
and then they had made like an audio
tape that was usually how they
communicated they either sent letters to
the media and like you know insisted you
have to read this or you have to play
this like on the air or we're gonna kill
her or whatever so they did that so they
sent an audio tape to um a radio station
and basically said I guess because they
figured out because remember how I said
like at first they were like oh well
they kidnapped her so they could trade
her for the two guys that got um
arrested for Marcus Foster's murder
but I guess they figured out well that's
that shit's probably not gonna happen
because they're not just gonna let two
[__] murderers walk free right so
they decided to maybe do something else
maybe something I'm I'm assuming that
they were trying to get like maybe
public sympathy so what they did was
they contacted the media and said we'll
let Patricia go
if her dad Randolph Hearst
feeds all the poor people in California
or just in that one area
I think it was California and I'm just
like um how's it going to do that yeah
well that's what he said he's like now
come on I got a lot of money but not
that much money you know what I'm saying
there's a lot of [__] poor people
okay what infrastructure do you do that
you just send out a bunch of trucks well
that's okay so what they did so this is
what happened yeah so they're basically
like yeah we have to like under I guess
like under a certain thresh or all the
people that were needy or whatever
now uh Randolph Hearst he's kind of like
uh yeah I'm pretty sure that would cause
and I think like since then like people
have done like how much that actually
would have cost to do and it's like it
would have been like 400 million dollars
or something like that
and um what he did was he kind of did
like kind of a half measure where he's
like well I'll tell you what I'll give
you guys like two million dollars and
then they put together it took them like
a week or ten days or something like
that
um but they put together this kind of um
this little group called people in need
it gave them like two or three million
dollars and they got a bunch of food and
again like put it in trucks and to
distribute it and basically yeah and
they said he handed out UNICEF packages
and right beans and rice big bags well
yeah and then we'll yeah we'll get in
and out of it but it's just like I don't
and uh for my by all accounts it was
something of a cluster [__] which like I
said they didn't really have the
infrastructure for doing something like
for Distributing anything they had to
like Cobble it together really quickly
um so there was that and I did like on
the documentary that I watched earlier
they did have some interviews with
people that had come down to get food
and they're you know there's one woman
on there going you know I hate to take
advantage of like this girl getting
kidnapped and everything but you know I
gotta feed my kids so you know what I
mean one bag of rice right you know so
it's that kind of thing
so it was kind of a [__] show
um you know which okay I mean at least
he did kind of make a Goodwill gesture
but blah now he's just he's just trying
to beat the demands right and and
because he basically said well the
demands you give me are like impossible
yeah
um so which you know fair enough like I
said he's got money but I guess he
doesn't have that much money and you
can't like always access it I suppose
so
what happened after that though because
the food distribution was such uh a
[__]
and because
uh Randolph Hearst came out in the media
later and said you know I tried to do
what they want but what they're asking
me is impossible so you know it's out of
my hands is the wording that he used uh
like it's now out of my hands I'm
assuming he met like the fate of his
daughter was now out of his hands
because he said that
um at this point it seems that Patty
maybe turned a corner a little bit I'm
not really sure if
like I said I'm not really sure what was
going on behind closed doors like while
she was with this group because she was
with them like I said for a long time
and so it could have been that when her
dad came out and said yeah we try to do
this but we [__] it up
um you know and it's out of my hands now
they might have spun that to her as your
dad doesn't give a [__] about you like
he didn't do this like I don't I'm not I
don't know I'm just speculating so that
might have kind of like pushed her more
in the direction of maybe like
sympathizing with them or something of
that nature I'm not really sure
but basically she comes out later on and
she and there's audio tapes you can hear
them they're all over YouTube and
everything of her talking uh like all
the communiques that they sent and she
was basically at this point like because
prior to this she had sent you know
audio tapes of her being like I'm okay I
don't want you guys to worry and all
this other kind of stuff but then this
one was like I can't remember exactly
like the wording that she used but she
said oh well you said something like oh
it's out of your hands you might as well
have said I wash my hands of it and she
sounded like she was getting like pissed
about it you know what I mean and uh and
she also said oh the food you
distributed was you know subpar
basically it's like it wasn't anything
like like our family would eat like just
accusing them of cheaping out like that
kind of stuff I'm trying to feed as many
people as possible right right you know
so so she was mad about that they just
they were they were guilt tripping her
Yeah well yeah I kind of feel like maybe
that's what was going yeah that's that's
the technique oh you see we asked her to
feed us and what what do you eat at your
house or you eat Flamingo and this nah
he dropped off rice and [__] spam
Kansas spam okay that's that's peasant
food you know he didn't hand out flaming
yawn and everything so if he their
guilt-tripping her which is that's what
that's how you that's how it's done like
I told you in that book rape of the Mind
so she's trying to they're turning her
against her family yeah and and you'll
see that like as the time goes on like I
said if you listen to the audio tapes
that they sent to the media with her
talking on them
um over the months she starts getting
more and more you know she starts
calling her parents like pigs and
fascists and stuff like that
um you know and [__] on them and
whatnot when before like I said all she
was saying was I'm okay I don't want you
guys to worry about me they're not
hurting me blah blah you know what I
mean but she just got more and more
militant I guess like as time went on
they knew what they were doing yeah
probably oh yeah they just stumbled they
just stumbled on the on the techniques
of brainwashing
maybe they read it read up on it
the thing is like sometimes I don't know
if it's that calculated it's like
sometimes you just kind of like do stuff
that works then you just kind of
consciously go along with it right yeah
they were just following their instincts
on how to get somebody to turn against
their families
and it just ended up to be that way and
then the incarceration
uh what they were doing to her but you
haven't got into that yet they're
keeping her in a closet well because she
I didn't get into that yet because that
was something that she just came out
with later yeah so I'm not really sure
if it was going on at the time and she
just didn't talk about it or because it
really didn't come out until her trial
like how they were supposedly treating
her yeah so if it's true but possibly
probably I mean maybe like I said I'm
not denying it she was abducted they
probably kept her in the closet
yeah at least for a while until they had
a cell yeah I think they kept her in
there for a while and then like they let
her out and then I guess they were sure
like you know what I mean she also said
she was raped multiple times but you
know I don't know if that's true or not
either but she did say that later on
like at the trial uh
which is probably well
they might have just had sex with her
and then later on she said like well you
know it was raped because she probably
felt she didn't have a choice
maybe because yeah xanadas said the
documentary I saw said that she had a
love affair with one of these guys
that's the thing it's like some see
that's that's the thing about this case
and like I said I don't have a dog in
this fight I'm not coming down on one
side or another like I said I don't want
to be in a case of being like people
saying they got raped in me saying oh no
you didn't because I don't [__] know
I wasn't there but it's like I have
heard
um that maybe she did actually like fall
in love with one of those guys and like
have a romance with them yeah but that
about it happened after the abduction
right well yeah it did it did okay well
then that goes so I'm not really sure if
that's it falls into Stockholm right
syndrome and and the things that
happened during brainwashing like I said
she calls it she called it rape
and at the time it could have been that
the dudes that were doing it didn't
really even realize that that's what it
was right they might have just made a
hit on her and she responds okay
right because they're very compli pliant
they don't want to get in trouble well
yeah because maybe you don't know what
they're gonna do if you say no right so
to avoid getting beaten they'll just go
okay
which like I said is still rape by the
way yeah yeah
although
yeah it is but she probably should have
said okay I'll do it I don't want to but
I'll do it that would make it right yeah
dude might have thought if someone's
juice might have thought it was
consensual
yeah some dudes are just don't don't
understand Body Language they don't know
yeah how women operate They Don't Really
they can't put themselves in that girl's
shoe shoes you know what I mean
um so you know these are young guys and
not the brightest bunch
so there is a chance that that that
those dudes didn't think it was right oh
she loves us you know yeah yeah I mean
maybe they were they were deluded too
maybe yeah you diluted right yeah
they're like oh she's all into it we're
heroes yeah we're heroes of the [__]
saving the people
she's on our side now
she's having sex with us all so you
don't know you had to be there that's
what yeah see the to see the the tone of
it now they're smacking her around and
[__] that you know yeah you I mean
obviously that's bad but yeah that's
like other things like that are more
Insidious that's like a more Insidious
yeah manner of control because it's not
overt like you said they're not punching
her in the face yeah they're not doing
anything like that but it's like just
just that pressure that's just that
implied threat was there she feels that
she has to she has to say yes
yeah yeah that's a whole other thing
that's why this shit's so complicated
you know what I mean because you don't
really know what was going on
uh Mr 88 said if she was in captivity it
was rape yeah that's the thing it's not
like I mean they took her from our
apartment I I don't really think yes we
I have seen like one or two things say
it's like oh maybe the abduction was
staged but honestly 99.9 of the sources
I saw like nobody really disputes that
she actually was taking bottles yeah if
you're she's captive then it was right
whether she said yes or no or not but
then you have to understand how
delusional these dudes are yeah either
way I'd punish them yeah either way well
they all got yeah
but the chances are those dudes thought
that they swung her
some of the members that that survived
like they went in prison and they're out
now and stuff like that and they were
talking about it and they were saying
that yeah some of them absolutely did
think that it was so cool that it's like
we got this rich girl and she like to
completely flipped and joined us and
joined us yeah so it's like without
really considering that maybe it wasn't
entirely yeah her choice yeah without
considering what it the pressure she was
under
because they can't put themselves in her
shoes a lot of people you know slip
statistic they only see things from
their point of view and they were like
oh we're good guys and now she knows it
that's you know that's probably exactly
yeah maybe how they were the good guys
now she that's probably like yeah she's
woken up yeah she's woke now
yeah
that's right probably what happened
yeah that sounds yeah that that actually
yeah I was a soldier the Army you join
is the right Army no matter what uniform
it is from your point of view it's the
right Army so these guys think they're
in the right Army that they're they're
the good guys
they don't see themselves the bad guys
they think they're the good guys well
that's kind of the scary thing about bad
guys is that they always think they're
the good yeah yeah that's what makes
them scary yes a shock shock people the
Nazis thought they were the good guys
there's a hilarious [__] shot there
who the [__] was that who's that cop
that British comedy sketch they did that
whole yeah
are we the Baddies
they were the good guys guys destroying
evil and protecting their own that will
never not make me laugh saving Europe
from evil you know by making it all
Germany just everything's narrative and
they believed it because they they saw
themselves as the good guys yeah well
they kind of saw themselves in a couple
of the surviving members said this too
they kind of saw themselves initially at
least before
[__] and started going sideways
um they initially kind of saw themselves
as like Robin Hood yeah yeah you know
what I mean which like I said you know
yeah I'm telling you yeah that was rape
legally that's rape well yeah and Mr it
said yes Jen even if she consented it
would still be interested as captive
yeah because she's not in the right
frame of mind she's not a normal yeah
and like I said she's been kidnapped
yeah she didn't choose to be taken for
most southern states if you kidnap
somebody that's a life sentence yeah so
anything that happens there is Stockholm
Syndrome she can't consent she's not
free to consent really yeah she doesn't
have she can't walk away
so yeah
it's the same thing that happens with
serial killer because girlfriends a lot
of them
yeah they can't walk away from the dude
they'll even help him kill other women
yeah so it's just Stockholm syndrome and
we talked about that too like when we
talked about like um like serial killer
couples and things like that because I
always find that an interesting Dynamic
too because 99 times out of 100 I feel
like most of the time the women in that
occasion in that equation would not kill
anybody if they hadn't met that dude
here's another thing when you say oh you
can't put all this on guys
there's this professional escort that I
listen to on on YouTube her name is Ayla
aiella Ayla I've mentioned her a couple
times
her and two or three other girls were
streamers they were streaming live over
stream mate they had a girl with him who
was like one of the wildest ones
doing all this [__] on stream and all
this lesbian type stuff
she eventually left and went back to her
parents and then totally flipped and she
thought that those other girls had made
her do it and that they had
brainwashed her into it
all right and some people's minds can
rewrite history
she didn't charge him but that's what
she told her family
but she's just doing that to save her
own ass no but it could they were living
together in one apartment so it may have
been from her point of view the peer
pressure
she felt she couldn't say no
today yeah I can see that then it was
like letting down the other girls they
wouldn't be able to make the bills and
and that oh well if I don't do this with
this girl on film she won't make this
money and she'll use it against me I
don't I have to pretend like I want to
do this
so there's that aspect too it can happen
between girls yeah
in sexual situations screaming in the in
the sex industry yeah I mean nobody got
murdered nobody got murdered
the human mind is weird
it is and Ayla was like wait a minute
hold on how could that be because you
came up with this idea and this idea and
you did this and you you were into that
what the hell are you talking about but
in retrospect
in order to absolve herself to her
family and her own conscious
because she went Christian and all that
I think
uh well that is one of those she rewrote
that history right is that she was
forced into all that
but she didn't go to the cops over it
she signed all those consent forms
passed all that [__] because you got to
go through a process to become yeah you
can't just yeah we're going through all
of that right now yeah you can't just
hands Us open in a couple days you can't
just like put naked [__] up on the
internet and like you you gotta sign
consent forms your stuff next to your
driver's license to make sure everybody
is of age each video and nobody's gonna
get in trouble each video and each
photograph you post it all has to
there's consent forms and you have to
proper ID on each one of those where it
goes
it's it's legal you're you're making
legal porn yeah it's not just hey put
those up there yeah you can't do that I
mean what you can but you can't you can
get trouble get in trouble
uh Mr 88 said Simon Whistler who I love
Simon Whistler by the way he's got like
a bajillion channels but he's [__]
awesome I love him uh he released an
episode about uh Paul Bernardo and Carla
Homolka yeah we did a video about them
uh today oh [__] I'm gonna have to go
watch that maybe I can watch it tomorrow
at my lunch hour she was the worst of
the two I've heard that yeah about those
two uh and actually actively raped girls
that they kidnapped even when Paul was
not present yeah I think that situation
because I think we talked about them on
the guy with the van
no these were I think they were Canadian
they were the Barbie and Ken Killers oh
those two yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
they arrived they're all like yeah yeah
yeah they're all like super good looking
and everything
um I think we talked about them on one
of our Valentine's Day shows like one of
their killer couple shows and yeah I
think that was one of the rare cases
because there's more than one I'm not
saying that it's like always but girls
are stealing that's one of the rare
cases where she was worse than he was
yeah
but you know what I mean weird man
but it doesn't usually happen I mean
like I said 99 times out of 100 it's the
other way around there's one in the 80s
the most fat looking dude like look like
Cal off Sanford his son big fat redneck
type dude he had a hot girlfriend from I
remember they had a van and they'd go
around and pick up underage girls
they both rape them and then kill him
she she'd run around and she'd make the
girls do stuff to her while she was
driving
and uh
the [__] boyfriend would just send
her out I think I think on at least one
occasion sent her out there to go kill
the girls herself and she had a gun on
him made them dig their own Graves and
told them they were she was she told
them they were that they were digging
their own Graves and she gunned them
down they were like 16. two of them
buried them I just can't imagine oh
[__] monsters man I can't imagine
I would I literally no situation where I
would even I mean I would have to hate
you a lot yeah a lot yeah and she was a
normal to even think about doing that
yeah and she was a normal looking woman
I want to say she was like maybe in her
late 20s early 30s so you never know and
I remember their names I just remember
their I remember his face
mostly and I remember the pictures of
the [__] victims I read a book about
it
a little soft cover and uh man I was
like [__] shocked man I was like I
can't believe that that [__] actually
happened and I was like I'm kind of in
denial I was like this has to be
sensationalized but no it wasn't
it was that damn blooded gasoline
I'm telling you man I can't understand
how something could be that mean
I'm pretty mean I'm not that mean
yeah you know I I [__] I couldn't do
anything like that to somebody just over
something as dumb as sex
I mean if it's Warfare you know what I
mean or you're fighting for the survival
of your people type of deal I can
understand killing enemies I mean
[__] ex-army infantry yes what you're
about
but what killing people over for sexual
well and just like innocent people just
people that you just like yeah picked up
randomly yeah you don't know them for
something that's a few minutes of wait
pleasure for you only uh this is a big
Power Trip I don't understand you gotta
have a [__] up ego you must be really
[__] a little person to get off on
something dumb like that yeah I would
dig yeah it would have a lot of hatred
but why would it manifest itself in a
sexualized I don't get it
you know I don't either so I'm kind of
weird and this is a woman doing it
and I understand that even less yeah
it's a woman doing it being a woman
myself and I'm just like you know and
I'm not saying I speak for all women
everywhere because obviously everybody's
different but
it's just evidently it was she was a
normal woman until he that dude got a
hold of her
and then she ended up raping and
murdering underage girls that was like
her thing
I don't understand that man how do you
how do you swing that
she got addicted to it it's [__] up
it's like something out of them Natural
Born Killers or something that movie it
is it's [__] up yeah
raping and killing underage girls
Ben says there are people quote unquote
yeah thank you for putting that in
quotes who squash small animals to
achieve sexual pleasure yeah crush is
what that's called yep nasty [__]
which
why how
um
just how could I just I don't understand
it's like it makes me want to cry just
thinking about it
you know what I mean I ain't like
it's got to be very rare
it better be yeah holy [__]
it's just
so yeah
um all right so where were we okay so we
were talking about like what's this
thing I could ever do that is my baby
[__] Exterminating a bunch of roaches
and get off on that die [__] I could
kill her roach is up I could kill a rose
I [__] hate roaches I do too other
than that they're more like machines
though they're not mad other than that I
don't really like I can't even kill a
spider you know yeah I like spiders I
don't like spiders I know he doesn't I
[__] hate roaches every time I see a
spider in the house I pick him up and
I'm just like you gotta get out of here
don't let
and I put him outside
but I do not like cockroaches but that's
really the only living thing that I
don't feel bad about killing is
cockroaches
and maybe house flies but other than
that I'm just like not I don't I don't
kill anything I'm like hey man they got
a right to be here much as I do all
right I'm just letting them live their
life as long as they're not bothering me
now Mr 88 saying it has to do with
childhood Batman okay whatever the thing
is is that how do these serial killers
get these girls into that they get their
girlfriends into it
like that I think I think I mean those
those what's his name Mary West
Rosemary Westbury West she the victims
that survived so that she was worse than
he was yeah sometimes but like I said
started it he got her into it he'd been
doing it on his own like I said I always
wonder though and there's no way to run
this experiment obviously unless you
have a time machine
is that I always wonder if these women
had been left to their own devices and
didn't meet this [__] would they
have turned out normal I think so they
probably would have I think most of the
time some kind of synergy builds up yeah
look at like Myra hindley for example
had she not met Ian Brady would she have
killed anybody yeah they torture that
little girl [__] recorded it and [__]
yeah terrible [__] I I don't I think she
had never met that dude I don't think it
ever would have even occurred to her to
do that [__]
but she just got all [__] swept up in
it
and that's what happens it's like that
frog and boiling water man yeah
you know they they work on you slowly I
guess I don't know I don't know how it
happens I'm not saying that there aren't
some women out there that are like
sadistic and [__] up because there
absolutely are I'm just saying that a
lot of those killer couples cases I
think in most cases the women if they
had not met that dude I don't think they
would have done the [__] the thing is is
there some something hidden in a lot of
women that they can activate
or did he chose her did he choose her
because she had that ability
to do that yeah maybe maybe he's good at
like picking that [__] out yeah he's
like Mr 88 makes a good point said
usually the women are also severely
abused and are trying to impress or stay
in the good graces of their partner yeah
and maybe that's why they're worse in
some cases because they're like trying
to up the ante they're like look I can
do this [__] like even better than you
can kind of thing like I mean we're
[__] up than you are yeah I know but
well it matters to them I guess because
that's kind of because they're messed up
yeah let's get back to this case all
right thank you
I'm gonna need another drink
all right okay so um so where were we
okay so after the whole debacle with the
food distribution the food wasn't good
enough it wasn't enough of it blah blah
and so two months after uh Patty Hearst
was kidnapped so this is in April of
1974. she um sent an audio tape that
said by the way you guys
um I've joined the SLA cause I'm all in
with them now and I have taken on the
new name Tanya
uh she was named after I guess like one
of uh Che guevara's girlfriends or
something like that so like I said they
all took on new names which like I said
very culty always watch if somebody asks
you to do that
um and she started calling her parents
pigs and fascists and whatnot
so probably the most famous uh aspect of
this whole entire thing
happened uh not too long just like a few
days after that tape was received by the
media this was April 15 1974.
there was a quite a violent bank robbery
uh this was in uh Hibernia it was
Hibernia Bank which is in uh the sunset
District branch of it on Noriega Street
in San Francisco
now very famously on the um surveillance
footage
they show like um the members like
coming into the bank they all had you
know automatic weapons and they're all
like ordering everybody to get down and
[__] like that and uh Patty Hearst
carrying a gun finger on the trigger
looking like she [__] owned the place
you know what I mean now what they did I
guess there wasn't any audio at least
like because I was watching a
documentary about it and they were
talking to the FBI guys that worked on
the case
and as this never occurred to me that
they would do this but I'm like well duh
like once they said it I was like oh
well yeah it's obvious in retrospect
they're like usually if we have a case
where there's like surveillance footage
and there's no audio it's like what
we'll usually do is we have like a
contingent of like you know deaf people
um because they can read lips so it's
like so we just go in there and they
tell us what the people said you know
what I mean just like they said well if
there's uh audio tapes we always like
bring in blind people because they have
like more uh they have better hearing
and so maybe they can hear some [__] on
the tape that'll tell us like where it's
coming from and [__] like that so that's
what they did they brought in like a
bunch of deaf people and said what is
Patty Hearst saying on this tape because
we can't hear her
apparently what she was saying while she
was in this bag like I said she's
holding the she's holding the the gun
and she's got the finger on the trigger
and everything like that apparently what
she said was I'm Tanya up against the
wall [__]
which certainly doesn't sound like uh
somebody that was not into it but like I
said that's you know we'll get into that
in a little bit but that's apparently
what she was saying like on the
videotape up against the wall
[__]
now while the robbery was taking place
uh two guys like customers like actually
walked into the bank and got shot now
neither one of them was killed they were
both wounded
um but yeah so uh they were but they
wasn't Patricia Hearst that shot them it
was like some of the other members
now according to some later accounts
like that kind of came out later like
you know during her later trial and
whatnot
they were trying to argue like I said
that perhaps Patricia Hurst was being
forced into like being like doing the
bank robbery like against her will maybe
um because some of the witnesses said
well she was like walking way behind
them and then like some later said and
there were photographs of this too uh
that the FBI had that some of the other
members of the SLA were actually
pointing their guns at her as though
they were saying it's like hey you
better go along with this kind of [__]
and make it look good or whatever
because that's kind of like what they
were arguing so uh so yeah
so this was like a huge big uh bank
robbery and very very famous uh photo
from a very famous uh surveillance
footage and that's just kind of like
[__] went crazy because you have to
think at this point
you know the the kidnapping of Patricia
has been a huge news story for like the
last couple of months and then the FBI
like everybody's working on it and
they're just like we don't know where
she is and it's like now she's saying
she's joined them what the [__] is going
on like her family or like we still
think you know we want her back and it's
like we don't we don't know what her
deal is and they're forcing her to say
that and then all of a sudden everybody
turns on the news and sees surveillance
footage of her with a [__] you know
M1 carbine or whatever saying like up
against the wall [__] like in a
bank robbery so everyone was like what
the [__] is actually going on here so
there was that
for the you young uh Whipper Snappers
into the gun scene the the 30 carbine I
had one of them the 30 carbine was the
AR-15 of the 70s and the 80s by the time
I got one they were old hat though
piece of [__]
only the Winchester's pretty good but
funny funny little carving
Tyler the guy says I never thought about
it this way Tyler guy says that's a
horrifying idea that you could possibly
meet a woman fall in love with her and
never know that if she ended up with the
wrong guy she could have become a killer
thank you thank you that's what I was
[__] yeah and I was like is this
hidden but see you never know you never
know what kind of because you know yeah
people are their own you know they have
their own choices in Destiny everything
like that but
um people are also influenced by other
people around them too you have to get
them at the right stage of Life they had
to be they had to be malleable they
couldn't be a fully formed identity I
don't I don't think
they have to be somebody who's kind of
[__] up yeah they'd have to obviously
have some kind of because I don't think
you could just talk anybody into that
[__]
um you know not without some severe
young and deprived brainwashing but yeah
if somebody that was damaged in some way
um somebody that was vulnerable in some
way and you could exploit that yeah and
they'll do whatever you say to begin
with
yeah they're real submissive to you
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
kill somebody together we'll be love
forever okay that's what that was yeah
okay
well that's what that Barbie couple I
think that's how that started did if you
kill somebody together we we will We
Can't Break Up
yeah how romantic yeah very not very
romantic I think that's how that started
if I remember correctly
girls if your boyfriend says that to you
run very fast in the other direction I
don't run [__] run to the police
station
yeah because get them off the streets
for the benefit of mankind please just
if you just run he'll do it with
somebody else that's true get that
[__] locked up we didn't have to
kill this 15 year old girl
and we will love each other forever only
a [__] ass [__] would come up
with some [__] like that anyway Right
the dude even just stinks that way no he
he doesn't need to go to jail he needs
to die all right going to jail is [__]
yeah he's probably just headed in the
face of the shovel and bury him call me
all right
because that's no good is ever going to
come no no good is everything
people as well and we talked about this
before like I said I'm all for like
people that commit crimes and Chile
especially if they're kind of [__]
crimes you know once they've done their
time and they let them out okay fine let
them integrate back into society people
with that serial killer mindset though
I'm not really sure that that can be
fixed no
I'm not really sure that can be found
once they do that that's it they need to
be locked up and either for life or
executed
that's it you can't release them
I mean even if you even if they never
did it again you could never like trust
them no never you'd always be like
looking over your shoulder nobody would
want them living next door and it's the
same thing as a serial rapist
you know as soon as the guy's identified
as a serial rapist he's got to get a
life status he's
that's it he'll just continue to do it
so
the three strikes you're out law I think
it's bad that's [__] but there's got
to be exceptions they know that there
are things like serial killers and
serial rapists so they just need to
watch those
if a dude gets convicted twice of that
[__] on that second time he shouldn't be
able he can't yeah they're like well
that's it you're a silly rapist dude
yeah we're just gonna throw in a hole
there's a lot of other things it's not
just that they get picked up for a lot
of other shits that's related to that
like attempted abductions and [__]
[__] peeping Tom [__] and [__] uh
what do you call it flashing people same
dudes that are cereal
yeah right a whole bunch of other [__]
yeah they do like [__] like that like
well I'm not going full whole hog this
time around but they're just gonna do a
little minor [__] but yeah that's what
they do you need to have a professional
observe them figure them out and if
they've become identified as that then
you got to send them to then it'd be
prison you send them to what they call a
hospital for uh you know what I mean
mental health
yeah that's another thing you can do
Tyler the guy said I'm usually against
the death penalty but sometimes I'll see
a case so bad that I'm like yeah okay we
can go ahead and kill this one yeah
pretty much uh I'm with you on that no
in no way am I against the death penalty
not here in the United States I know
England has a thing against it and I
don't think Canada has it because they
come from a history
where they hung everybody for anything
you know if a kid stole a [__]
piece of bread they'd [__] hang it's
like I said that's way too fast that's
not what we're talking about here this
is America we got real criminals okay we
got real criminals here you can't just
let them walk around what are you
talking about no the problem here is
that they make the execution a big
[__] expensive thing that takes
[__] 20 or 30 years it needs to be
like China like we know you did it we
got you're dead to rights you're gonna
die today okay [__] all this appeal [__]
they take them out and just shoot him
I've seen the videos they just shoot
them in the back of the head John
and like that's how you do it
because
that's the same kind of [__] you see on
a battlefield Battlefield execution
that's humane
soldiers like me were dying much worse
just torn to [__] shreds by [__]
shrapnel you know
and I didn't commit guys like me weren't
committing any crimes dudes in other
armies weren't committing crimes they
were just doing what they're told so
that's the easy way out just shooting
somebody in the back of the head
if you're a [__] serial killer or a
serial rapist I think serial rapists
need to go I mean well serial rapists is
generally just a serial killer that
hasn't killed anything yeah yeah they
just need to go I mean it's the same
mindset you'd have some [__] go well
that's his sexual orientation though we
can't we gotta nobody's gonna say that
yeah yeah they gotta kill that [__]
nobody's gonna say that that's [__] up
in any [__] everybody thinks that's
[__] up everybody's got [__] moms
you know what I mean and [__] wives
and daughters and [__] you can't have
those dudes walking around
it's true yeah
uh Hey Dave's here what's up I haven't
talked to you because I haven't talked
to you for a while yeah because we
haven't been to mannequins in a few
weeks yeah said hey YouTube been busy
yeah so we just thought I'd pop in here
and say hello well hello hello Dave how
are you
all right so
where was I okay so yeah the bank
robbery bank robbery it's a famous
famous uh [__] video it is footage
yeah like I said I could all pin Ash and
[__] with your [__] 30 carbine and
her I think she didn't she have a beret
on I think she did yeah well okay I
don't remember if she had the bereton in
the footage but I the famous photo of
her standing in front of the SLA flag
she had a beret on yeah because she's
I'm just like ooh okay so uh so yeah
revolutionary fashion show right
but yeah so um so yeah so she's in there
and like I said I don't think that video
really helped her cause any because like
I said it really did look like
she was really on board with the [__]
even though later on it did come out
because they had some other photographs
and stuff like that that showed that
some of the other members of the SLA
were maybe possibly like pointing guns
at her instead of at the other people at
the bank which maybe would suggest that
they were kind of like hey yeah it could
have been muzzle and discipline that's
what I mean that's so yeah there's
there's no way of no but that's I'm just
saying that's what the defense are in
the Infantry we are constantly pointing
muzzles at each other there's no choice
everybody's got guns and there's [__]
dozens of you in the back of a [__]
truck or in a [__] helicopter you're
pointing guns at each other all the time
you just
trust your [__] fellow Soldier these
that he knows what he's doing that that
shit's all safe and there isn't around
him then he's not gonna sneeze and blow
your head up yeah I've never seen it
I've never seen an accident discharge
like that
everybody was good with them so it was
okay if your buddy pointed a guy at you
his happy he's just cradling it and
turning you know what I mean it's got a
point
muzzle sweep and everything it's not
just you're not on the Range you're
you're a professional
but that's probably what they're doing
there's robbing the bank and they were
sweeping sweeping the muzzles across
people yeah it's possible that's that
that's what it is but I'm just saying
that the defense argues it's like look
they're pointing the guns at her which
meant that they were
forcing her to go along with it probably
not even though like I said yeah it
could it could go either way honestly
so yeah so that was uh very big very
famous uh kind of thing that happened
not too long after that on May 16 1974.
there's a place in Inglewood California
called Mel's Sporting Goods and there
were two members of the SLA who are a
married couple named uh William and
William and Emily Harris now back then
like I said everybody took silly new
names uh so they were actually known as
Tico and Yolanda for whatever reason
so they're in this Sporting Goods store
uh shoplifting I think they bought some
[__] too but I guess maybe they didn't
have enough money so they're like well
maybe we need some more [__] so we're
gonna steal it I heard that they that
William was stealing a pair of socks I
don't know if that's true or not that's
like one of the cops said but he was
like stealing a pair of sweat socks or
something like that
so him and his wife are leaving the
store now
Patty Hearst was in the van across the
street like while they were shoplifting
right
so what happens is that the manager sees
them stealing [__] from the store and he
goes out after them like to confront
them like hey [__] is you gonna
pay for that or whatever and then uh
William and the store manager started
like kind of scuffling right and during
this William had a pistol and it fell
out of his waistband
and then at that point Patty Hearst took
it upon herself
to essentially open fire on the front of
the store
so that her compatriots could get away
like she didn't kill anybody shouldn't
hurt anybody but she just like [__]
opened up yeah on the front of the store
like shot it all up
um you know so the manager was gonna
shoot back at her but she was like holy
[__] what the [__] is going on just
because she's like she was like an
automatic weapon Army yeah so uh so
there was that so she actually helped
them get away and then the two of them
like the three of them actually like
hijacked a couple cars and kidnapped the
owners like from the store
one of the owners apparently I don't
know if it was the owner's son or
something like that but he was like um
he thought Patty Hearst was just the
bee's knees he thought she was like
super friendly and all this other kind
of stuff which I was like strange but
I'm like okay
um now what ended up happening on this
particular day after they had done this
[__] shootout and all that and the
shoplifting
meanwhile the cops had figured out
where the slas like Hideout was and so
they had gone and like surrounded it now
apparently
uh William and Emily and Patty
I guess they heard about it and so they
went someplace else or they were told
about it so they didn't go back to The
Hideout they [__] off and like went
someplace else right
but what ended up happening was either
that day or the next day I can't
remember exactly
the cops like I said surrounded the slas
um you know Hideout and they at first
this was in La by the way because you
know the whole thing had started in San
Francisco but there was so much heat on
the SLA in San Francisco that they
[__] off to LA but it took like the
cops a long time to figure out that they
had moved to LA
one thing that they said that was
interesting on the documentary was that
um they were like well the police
departments in San Francisco and La were
like very very different whereas like
the San Francisco Police Department
would were a lot more chill
and probably wouldn't have just like
shot you in the face when you walked out
but the LAPD they're like were very very
militarized and they like really did not
[__] around so it's like basically they
were like well come out right now and
then they're just like okay never mind
we're blowing the [__] up so so
basically that's what happened they
asked them to all come out they just
like come out and you won't be hurt blah
blah and
um none of them would come out though
and apparently no one's entirely sure
the story usually goes that the SLA
members started shooting out the cops
first
um I don't know if that's the case but
that's usually the narrative that uh
that you hear so the SLA member started
shooting said hey we're not coming out
um you know we're gonna fight to the
death or whatever so the cops obliged
and uh started shooting back so I think
like the shootout lasted like two hours
I believe
and in the end they were throwing in
some uh tear gas canisters and
apparently one of them exploded or some
[__] like that and like set the house on
fire
so in this standoff I guess if you want
to call it that
um I mean they shot the [__] out of the
place too I think they shot like 5 000
rounds or something like that
uh so Donald defreeze was killed uh most
people think that he shot himself in the
head uh rather than be taken alive
uh and Angela Atwood Nancy Ling Perry
William wolf
um Patricia saltzick I think is how you
pronounce her last name and Camilla Hall
uh members of the SLA were all killed
now
um
so the cops
one of the FBI guys or the SWAT or
whoever were doing the [__] or the LAPD
guys they were like well we when we did
The Siege we weren't actually sure if
Patty Hearst was in there or not but we
he's like these the cops were like we
basically wanted these people dead so I
mean he basically said essentially that
so it's like he didn't say that they
didn't care if she was in there or not
but they were basically like well
[__] happens kind of attitude I kind of
got that impression that that's what he
was talking about
um now according to some SLA members
later on like they were interviewed they
said that cops absolutely knew that
Patty Hearst was not in there so I guess
they kind of felt that it was safe to
just like blow everybody else away I
don't really know
but uh but they kind of made it seem
like because they made a big show of you
know yeah they pulled out all the bodies
um after the fire fight was over and you
know they came out to the media and it's
like we wanted to inform the Hearst
Family that and they drew it out like it
was suspense like I was you know what I
mean like I'm watching her on the
documentary I'm like would you just tell
the man if his daughter's dead or not
it's like they're just like like it's a
[__] movie ending or some [__] like
that but he's like you know which we
wanted to tell that Patty Hearst was not
among the bodies found you know what I
mean because she had [__] off with
like those other two that she did the
robbery with so they actually went on
the run and they were on the run for a
long time like they didn't um the cops
had no [__] idea where they went and
they actually had some people helping
them
too like just people that they knew
through like I said the SLA was not a
big group uh you know it was maybe 11 12
people but they did have some people
that were kind of like sympathetic to
their cause or whatever so you know they
could kind of go around and they had
friends of friends that would like give
them money and like give them a place to
stay like for brief periods of time and
[__] like that
so basically after it was determined
that Patty Hearst was not
among the dead
um they basically issued arrest warrants
for uh the harrises the couple that had
done the you know the um the shoplifting
and for Patty Hearst uh and that would
be just all the felonies that they were
uh that they were they've seen the
kidnapping charges and all that other
kind of stuff
so
um basically Patty Hearst stayed with
them for a while um to a point where she
was helping them make bombs
um they actually used a couple of these
bombs they were in uh 1975 they were
actually going to blow up some cops
um but they weren't successful one of
them went off but it didn't hurt anybody
and the other one didn't go off at all
but she was like building bombs and [__]
like that
and uh I don't know if a lot of people
know this but there were actually two
more bank robberies uh that were pulled
off by SLA members one of them was in
Sacramento and that was in February of
1975 and there was another one in
Carmichael California in April of 1975.
now in this last one in Carmichael a
woman was killed a woman named myrnally
opsahl she was actually a customer she
was like you know an older she had four
kids or something like that she just
came in to make a deposit and um
apparently Emily Harris who was one of
the ones that had done the um the
shoplifting she actually uh shot the
woman like when the woman was trying to
run out of the bank and killed her so
you know there's murder again well like
I said they murdered that other dude
like earlier too
so finally after uh Patty Hearst and the
harrises were on the run for I believe
18 months it was like after the um the
fire fight
they actually uh finally tracked them
down because you know you have to think
she was on the FBI Most Wanted list and
everything like that so and everybody
was like why the [__] can't you find her
you know
um but it might have been because I kind
of feel like it might have been because
the SLA were such a small group they
were kind of like easy to it's not like
they had like super big connections like
all over the country or anything like
that they could just kind of wander
around whatever they wanted and nobody
knew where they were going
so they did finally catch up with them
though uh ironically back in San
Francisco
so Patty Hearst was arrested along with
another SLA member whose name was Wendy
Yoshimura and they actually did find
some uh money in the apartment that was
from the Carmichael robbery like it was
you know marked uh from the from that
bank so they knew that she was because
um Patty Hearst I don't think she'd been
in the bank for that one but she drove
the getaway car you know what I mean so
she was still involved in the ship
now apparently while she was being
arrested and she was being booked and
everything like that they asked her what
her occupation was Patty Hearst and she
said quote unquote Urban gorilla yeah so
all right
you know what I mean yeah so she was
still kind of in the thrall at this
point
now one thing that was brought up a lot
at her later trial was that when she was
arrested
um Patty Hearst only weighed 87 pounds
uh she looked bad I mean she looks kind
of sickly like it looked like kind of
some of her hair had fallen out how old
was she 19 20. and how tall was she
87 pounds
that's starvation okay
and her hair was falling out that's
stress I mean it looked like from the
pictures
she just looked real thin and real pale
um also she underwent um examination by
a psychologist and the psychologist
called her quote
a low IQ low affect zombie okay they did
an IQ test on her and apparently her IQ
had dropped to 112 whereas before it had
been 130 which is actually pretty good
fairly High
yeah um I don't know how accurate it
might have just been from stress and
everything like that checks out but um
horror and Trauma reduces people's
ability to to think that's why either
they'll call it like political terrorism
um what would be worth is it worse is
like what [__] Colonel Kurtz is
talking about and [__] Apocalypse Now
horrorism that's what the Mexican Mob
uses
someone does some really bad traumatic
[__] to you directly to you through
maybe your family your IQ will drop your
response to it will be childlike and
uncoordinated because you're a
psychological casualty
yeah and the military knows all about it
that's why sometimes I've said in
earlier shows that being me being in a
Recon platoon working with snipers and
other kind part of the job of of the
snipers that would give us OverWatch if
they were ever put on an attack is to
maximize
violence on the objection or excuse me
I've been drinking maximize violence on
the objection objective or maximize
horror on the object on the objective
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to cause psychological casualties
in the enemy
by doing bad things to them because
their response will be unorganized
you know and ineffectual
you can make your opponent dumb by
horrifying them
that's what happened to her
you put it under a lot of stress you
just your faculty start shutting down
yeah yeah I mean they said at least
according to the psychologist that
examined her after she was arrested
um not only that but they said she just
like I said she seemed real lethargic
um she seemed to like not remember a lot
from Pro from before the abduction yeah
uh she had taken up smoking like chain
smoking uh she had PTSD essentially she
had nightmares things like that you go
do you go to Yale get a high IQ genius
[__] you know what I mean he's
highfalutin and arrogant and real
intelligent and can do all this advanced
stuff you beat on him for a few days
even a few minutes
real bad and then give him an IQ test
it'll be lower
especially if it's the dude who heard
him making him giving him the test
yeah
[__] Soviets knew all about it
through brainwashing techniques you know
that's why they would torture people
you're a lot more receptive to new ideas
when you're in that state because you're
just trying to survive and you can't
think clearly well yeah and like I said
okay all right then okay then this okay
then you must be right
and usually the more intelligent a
person is the more self-doubt is in them
they don't have that what do they call
that
done increase they don't have they don't
they don't have like where the Dumber
you are like the more confident you are
right about everything
is the less confident they are so you
could use that as a [__] chisel to
get into a crack somewhere that's kind
of thing yeah yeah yeah High
Intelligence is not a
a big advantage
it depends it depends on the situation
when you're in a Savage environment it
will work against you because you'll
just suffer more
yeah
been there done that
but see the thing about it as we were
mentioning earlier
because the psychologist recognized
these signs of trauma in her obviously
but she didn't have any
quote-unquote mental illness you know
what I mean so the fact that they were
trying because as I said this is the
1970s is a 1975. it's like they didn't
really yeah people had heard the term
brainwashing but it wasn't like a
clinical term people didn't really know
that much about Stockholm syndrome they
didn't know anything like that so it's
like it wouldn't be you wouldn't really
be able to argue that it's like oh well
I robbed a bank and shot some
[__] because I was brainwashed
there wasn't any legal precedent for it
the closest analogy that a civilian
would understand especially a civilian
woman was that you fell in the clutches
of a bad boyfriend an abusive boyfriend
can get a woman to do all kinds of
[__] up [__] it's true all right and
it's
brainwashing basically and the dude is
just a [__] psycho and he's abusive
and he's just doing it by Instinct he
wasn't trained to be a brainwasher he's
just it's kind of what happened to him
maybe when he was a kid or yeah because
a lot of times they kind of repeat yeah
Cycles you're right and the next thing
you know
he's got his girlfriend out there
turning tricks for him and just doing
[__] [__] up [__] and he beats her
and stuff and she but she stays with him
she needs it well a lot of times a lot
of times too is they take away their
sister and self [__] yeah they take
away their yeah so that so they feel
like they can't get by without him and
also they sometimes they take away they
cut off all their um you know they they
uh alienate all their friends and their
family like cut them off from other
support systems the way there's no out
there things like that yeah it's like
take away their car they take away
anything that they have that gives them
like an independence basically what an
interrogator does an enemy interrogator
when you're in captivity by some kind of
an enemy Army and they're brainwashing
you for propaganda technique but they
don't really do that anymore it's a
waste of time it's really a thing of the
Cold War because they thought it would
be good to propaganda to get to get get
the world to see some American Soldier
[__] denounce his own country
but it backfired
if whenever they showed that [__] the
American people didn't didn't [__] go
I guess we are wrong you know what I
mean no the American people got pissed
off you tortured our soldier they
doubled down in the war effort yeah so
there's no reason yeah well
the Soviets projected their own
weaknesses onto other people
I feel like that happens it happens a
lot yeah we're like well they're cowards
and if we do this and we're kind of
cowardly if we you know they will Buckle
to us no they'll get stronger
you see America making the bank [__]
same problems that well Iraq now knows
that it's weak so it will listen to us
no it didn't we got ejected
Afghanistan now knows it's weak we can
do whatever we want no they ran us out
of there if you [__] with people they
get pissed off
pretty much everybody yeah I mean I kind
of feel it yeah they get tougher they
don't get we get mad they don't get they
don't get weaker they get tougher you
[__] with them enough they just get mad
who gets weaker or [__] Rich
[__] that have [__] coming
up out of these [__] Rich families
little laptops they are projecting their
weakness onto the world because they've
never they haven't even been in a fist
fight and they're commanding armies okay
they don't know that if you beat on a
[__] he'll get up eventually and
[__] kill you
all right it's just give him time you
can only [__] with people so yeah yeah
right right but you know these dudes
like I said that are commanded in
America even it's armies and it's
generals they've never been in a [__]
fist fight
they've never been in the [__] fist
fight you just look at their physical
[__] Fitness they look like [__]
because they are [__] the good ones are
all left long time ago
Mr 88 said what Tom is saying right now
about the um what we were saying about
the the abusive partners and stuff uh
ties directly back into the female
serial killer partner participant yeah
we had earlier yeah and why they've been
to do what they do yeah and like I said
it's a lot more complicated than just
saying that's why I don't really like
I'm really uncomfortable with people
saying like you know like like you know
people that are in abusive relationships
oh why don't you just leave it's like
it's not really that simple they're too
weakened to leave a lot of times they're
like there's a lot of other factors
going on and so that's kind of the thing
about I get that you know um when at
Patty Hearst trial where they were
trying to say that you know she got into
like the SLA like she started you know
believing them and like believing in
their cause and stuff and like
voluntarily because she even said
specifically on some of those audio
tapes people are saying I'm brainwashed
and that's ridiculous and all this other
kind of stuff she said all that stuff
like on the tapes
um but I don't know I I kind of
brainwashed people know they're
brainwashed in certain things yeah I
mean that's the thing too and it's an
abused abused girlfriend would have
defend the [__] the the boyfriend for
a long time until she's finally away
from me go yeah he did kind of trick me
that wasn't me you know yeah it happens
a lot like I said it's and it's no shame
against people it's like people are
imperfect or you know our brains betray
us all the time
um everybody
wants to have their kind of best put
their best face forward but it's like we
all have weaknesses we all have and a
lot of times if you don't know what your
weaknesses are like someone else can
spot them and can exploit them whether
they're aware of doing it or not so it's
like I don't really feel like I don't
know that's why I'm just kind of like
you should probably just be [__]
just chill out with people man because
it's like you don't know what they're
[__] what's going on in their life
and it's like [__] [__] can happen and
and even if you say oh that wouldn't
happen to me or that wouldn't and I you
know maybe I've said that a couple times
like when we talk about like [__] about
cults and stuff like that the only
reason I say I never get sucked into a
cult is because I'm not a joiner and if
anybody ever asked me to join anything
I'm just like no so it's like some
that's probably why but um because I
don't want to be around other people but
so I think that's probably why that but
it's just like I'm not saying that it's
like you know it might have happened to
me too like I could have like hooked up
with some dude that like seemed normal
at first and then you know he went kind
of crazy and crazy and like you don't
realize all the time I go crazy all the
time she gotta see it now
yeah but I've always known that you were
like that I've known you were like that
from the beginning
and plus I'm always just like what are
you why stop being crazy yeah
I think what happened in this case
I know we're not we're not done with it
we probably got a lot left yeah well not
a lot a lot but yeah it's not I've got
to talk about the trial and I know why
you know they're saying well
you know she must have joined you know I
mean she she must have knew I think what
happened was they've Duggar
she wasn't in her right mind she went
through the very essence of like
brainwashing
which is what happens to like an abused
girlfriend
she went along with it she thought she
was she thought she was in a right mind
though but that's that's the tricks that
Minds play and I think of the other SLA
members I don't think I don't think they
were the sharpest [__] tax you know
no they didn't and they were like oh she
joined us
so yeah that's just how they like I said
they they probably thought oh she like
woke up to the reality yeah that her
parents are like part of the problem
that are like oppressing all the people
yeah and you know she did say that kind
of [__] so they were probably it was
pressure she was a captive yeah she was
under all that pressure
and uh she thought she got recruited
because that's just the way the Mind
tries to defend itself
see this kind of [__] fascinates me
though because like I said it's so
complicated like everyone's motives are
so complicated and a lot of times I
think maybe I have the feeling and maybe
this is uncharitable but like just
listening to her talk and stuff like
that she didn't seem like the brightest
yeah um I knew she was very young like
in those tapes and stuff like that and
she was probably very vulnerable she was
probably very she's 17 she's in college
so they have this altruism into them
and uh these guys are telling her things
that are true to half true yeah the
methods that they're using are [__]
criminal right all right you don't
abduct people you don't murder people
you don't frog bags to try this is
[__] stupid because you're not gonna
build an army that way you're gonna get
[__] stopped into the ground yeah
they don't even need the Army the police
can do it which they did all right yeah
they killed half of them like I said it
had been better had they just [__]
they had [__] a Hearst why didn't
they make a newspaper yeah I have her as
the newscaster you know what I mean or
something like that they would have been
better at information Warfare that would
have been a lot because you couldn't
have [__] arrested him for it yeah
because it's not illegal because it's
not illegal and they could just sit
there and talk [__] until and if it was
true then people would have been
convinced and then they would have been
players and they said you're oh if
you're trying to get somebody over to
your point of view yeah it's always
better like terrorist [__] that's not
gonna work because everyone's been like
hey you're [__] murderous
[__] we don't want anything to
do with that there is always a place for
the gun I'm infantry there's always a
place for it but it's not this most
Warfare is [__] political it's
Warfare by other means and the
information and ideas
the guns always kind of like
when there's no other option you know
but the thing is it's the one of the
weaker options
that's uh you know
that's when the system's gone you use
that yeah and I get that they felt that
I mean yeah I I was listening to some
interviews like I said with some of the
SLA members that they didn't have any
they didn't weren't there like when the
abduction took place but they you know
were members of it and their whole thing
they started getting radicalized if you
want to use that word
um you know because of Watergate and
stuff like that but they said
particularly it was Kent State
um that actually if you guys remember
that we never did a show about that but
national guard shot up some [__]
students killed four and wounded nine I
think unarmed uh college students the
students were throwing rocks and Bricks
at them though and uh they opened fired
and that was like a big but they said
that was kind of like a big they said
you know it'd been like wake up call
wake-up calls with Vietnam and Watergate
and everything like that but they're
like that was kind of like the Catalyst
for holy [__] they're killing us
um that kind of like made them think
that they wanted to like fight back
against the system or whatever that's at
least that's what a couple of the
members like said that that was kind of
a big Catalyst for them
um Tyler the guy said the difference is
Tom is lovable crazy not oh [__] crazy
except when he's on Trend then yeah
Denny's oh [__] crazy I'm on train I'm
the [__] Green Goblin for [__]
that first Toby Maguire fire
Spider-Man but yeah most of the time
you're just like lovable crazy
like I said if you ever have a really
misery misery if you ever go oh [__]
crazy I'm just like you're doing that
again let's not do that
but yeah so um so as I mentioned because
they didn't really know a lot about
brainwashing and [__] like that
um and because it appeared from you know
all the uh [__] that she said like all
the audio tape because there was like a
lot of letters and audio tapes and all
this other kind of stuff that had been
released to the media that it looked
like she was going along with them
willingly so people found it hard to
believe and especially because the
prosecution pointed out the fact that
it's like you know she was with just
William and Emily Harris for you know 18
months or however long it was they were
on the run she could have escaped like
multiple times they're like look at the
you know for example the time when they
were you know when William and Emily
were in the store doing the doing the uh
you know shoplifting and it's like she
was just sitting out in the van she
could have just driven off you know what
I mean like while they were in the store
but she chose to you know shoot at the
front of the store and could have killed
somebody she didn't thankfully but you
know it's like so why did she do that
now I mean later on she came out and
argued it's like oh I had just been
trained to do that it's like I didn't
even think about it like she was like oh
some of my SLA brothers and sisters are
in danger and I have to make sure that
they get away and that was like she
wasn't really thinking about it but you
can see how
people would be less inclined to be
sympathetic because it really did look
like she was going along with and like I
said she probably had ample
opportunities to escape and she didn't
so that really kind of
didn't help her cause but like I said I
don't really like to lean too hard into
that because you know people say the
same thing about like abused wives and
things like why didn't you just leave
you could have just left and blah blah
and it's a lot more complicated than she
got captured if she did get captured I
think she did if she was a captive she
wasn't in the right state of mind she
couldn't
they they swung her but it was temporary
she couldn't think properly
Ben says in the end the SLA was just a
gang of bank robbers who pretended to be
social revolutionaries for kicks yeah it
really does kind of seem like that like
I said they really
yeah they made a big show about like
having all these ideals and everything
some of which sounded real good and
stuff but it's like they really didn't
the [__] that they were doing didn't
like I really don't see how they thought
that they were going to manifest any of
the stuff that they were talking about
yes they were trying to get attention I
mean that worked I guess but it didn't
really
rally anyone to their cause though they
were delusional yeah that I I just don't
think this is something that they read
about in some kind of marxist
publication they're probably looking at
Che Guevara and [__] like that
um because they they were this is an out
of date tactic that never really
succeeded succeeded you know especially
not after the 30s and the 20s
that era had gone had had gone by
technology and it would never never
happen in America the infrastructure
wouldn't allow it the term in Warfare
terrain dictates everything and the
American terrain doesn't allow it it's
got too much of a vast complex Road
system
it's too interconnected you can't
dominate the land space here
so no he there they were tripping they
were reading books to have any military
experience
it's just political Theory
they thought they could start a
rebellion no
not like that
not in a country this size
this diverse you know what I mean maybe
a little bit of European country a long
time ago with a limited Road system and
maybe like a couple of train tracks
going through it yeah but that's a by
American Standards that would be a local
event not a nationwide event you could
do [__] locally
you know in the United States locally
you know in Europe that local event
might be pretty big it might cover a
country but here that would just be
local
can't do it well and sometimes like it's
less so nowadays but I kind of feel like
before the Advent of the internet like
[__] Could Happen has stayed over and
you'd never hear about it yeah now you
say well wait a minute the bus fix over
through Russia it's a huge landmass yeah
but it like I said it was most of it was
controlled by a central train station in
Moscow and if you looked at where the
train tracks and the roads were it
wasn't a very big land mass the rest of
it was inaccessible and empty
so effectively by American Standards
during the Bolshevik Revolution Russia
was small
that would have been like the equivalent
of maybe like a state or two
it's just that it was kind of spread out
and thin thinly populated just little
roads going everywhere so the both of us
could do it because that would have been
a local Revolution
it ended up [__] affecting millions
of people though adversely
so yeah so um basically so they have
like all these psychiatrists come in to
have a look at her they have one from uh
UCLA and stuff like that he was actually
the court appointed one
um and he actually worked for free
after he examined her
um he was the one that actually wrote to
then President Jimmy Carter asking for
uh hers to be released because he
thought that she was a victim of
brainwashing and that she hadn't done
any of the stuff of her own volition
now um so she was in police custody for
several weeks and afterwards she came
out and basically said you know she
repudiated the SLA
um now her first you know so like you
said as soon as she was out of that
environment for a few weeks she came and
like denounced them you know what I mean
and said yeah they forced me to like do
all that stuff agree with Tyler said on
the bottom right there exactly my
brother said America is essentially 50
different countries banded together with
wildly different perspectives spread out
anyone who thinks they could take it
over are delusional yeah very much so
yeah it's just there's just so much it's
just so complicated it would be like
trying to take over all of Europe five
times over
basically it's not gonna happen
but so the first lawyer she got who um
was named Terence hallinan he actually
told her not to talk to psychiatrists
not to talk to anybody he wasn't going
to put her on the stand or anything his
whole thing was he thought that the best
defense because you couldn't really like
I said you couldn't argue brainwashing
they didn't really know about Stockholm
syndrome or anything like that so he was
saying that well let's say
that the SLA members drugged you like
you didn't know about it like they were
flipping you LSD or something like that
so you didn't know what was going on
most of the time and that's how they
force you into some [__] and like so you
know your judgment was impaired or
whatever
now for whatever reason
um that attorney didn't last too long
and then uh that attorney was replaced
with the very famous F Lee Bailey who
most people probably know from the O.J
Simpson trial but he was like even
famous before that
so he was gonna argue I don't think he
was going to use the word brainwashing
but he was gonna argue that she had been
coerced into doing this stuff if not
like I said and that was kind of like
the standard at the time
was yeah you could argue coercion for
committing a crime but it had to be like
clear and present danger kind of
situation it's just kind of like yeah I
robbed that store but like this dude had
a gun to my head making me do it it had
to be like you had to think your life
was in danger like right that very
second like I'm gonna be killed if I
don't do this right now
um they didn't really have any precedent
for somebody who'd been in captivity for
such a long time that she had
essentially like taken on perhaps the
beliefs of the people around her and so
even when she was able to escape like
she didn't and you know things like that
so they're like she almost kind of like
internalized
um you know their views and their
training and stuff because they did do
training they trained her to use all the
guns and they did all that other kind of
stuff too so um
so that's what F Lee Bailey was going to
argue so he was essentially going to
argue brainwashing but he just wasn't
calling it that he was basically saying
that she was like low-key coerced into
doing all this stuff and
you know people were saying well maybe
not it's not a winning strategy because
like I said it's never done never been
done before like you know you can't
really say that she's being forced right
then because she could have escaped any
time and it's like she didn't so there
was that whole thing
so F Lee Bailey comes on
um so she gets
um arraigned for the bank robbery like
the main bank robbery that had like the
whole video thing in it
now interestingly the judge on the case
who actually spoiler alert died like
halfway through and then was replaced
with another one
um
he seems like he was kind of biased
against her from the start like he he
seemed like even from before the [__]
even started like he wasn't buying this
whole she was coerced into stuff and so
it's almost like he wouldn't allow I
don't know it just seemed kind of biased
where it's like a lot of the evidence
that they were like the defense was
trying to introduce like let's you know
introduce all these audio tapes she made
with all these psychiatrists and all of
this other stuff and he wouldn't allow
any of that but he would allow like all
the stuff that the prosecution was you
know what I mean so it seemed like a
little bit one-sided is what I'm gonna
say
um so so there was that
and there was also kind of a thing where
F Lee Bailey probably
unwisely
chose to put Patty Hearst on the stand
and she didn't make a great impression I
guess
um she came across as like I said very
lethargic I guess that in the prison
they'd been giving her some drugs like
her psychiatric drugs or something like
that so maybe she was like zoned out a
little bit but everybody said she didn't
really make that great of an impression
like she seemed just like blah blah blah
she seemed uh robotic was the thing the
word that they used which you'd think
would have acted in her favor but I
guess it didn't dude probably in shock
and not knowing what the [__] she
actually did probably questioning
herself why the hell did I do this right
maybe yeah I can I can cut you gotta
understand she's 19. from a soft 19 20
something soft ass background okay this
girl's never been and [__] had a hard
day at her life [__] she wasn't had
never been under any kind of pressure
and she fell into the heads of these
[__] wild ass revolutionaries that
scared the [__] out of her and her
defense mechanism was kicked in and she
just yielded a lot a lot of young people
even even fairly strong young people
don't have a real strong Identity or
sense of self they kind of go with the
flow whoever's around them they're like
whoa okay this is what we're doing yeah
you don't really like that I feel like
you don't really come into your identity
until you're older yeah mid-20s maybe
even older than that I don't know mid by
mid-20s I kind of knew what my deal was
I didn't really [__] have Clarity
until I was [__] 30.
around 30. yeah and uh yeah I feel like
probably I'm like okay it's kind of like
and and and this is something a lot of a
lot of people [__] don't really
understand it's part of the reason why
I'm a real critic of the western system
boys frontal lobes do aren't do not
mature at the same rate that girls do
they have a big advantage over boys
during school years
especially when puberty hits
boys should not be in school as
teenagers they need to be doing
something else and then once
they're [__] 19 or 20 then they can
go back and cons once they've settled
down
and then you can learn a lot better
the only ones that end up getting
degrees and all these educations are
basically low testosterone males because
they're not under the effects of that
[__]
so what you have is you have [__]
betas
and kind of unfit unfit males getting
all the [__] education and Power
if the education system was different
you'd have better men in power
better quality man
so uh and and that's that's just biology
boys mature a lot more slowly than girls
do did you we just didn't evolve for
that we evolved more for action than
thinking
and ethnicity is a factor not
everybody's the same some people produce
a lot more of this testosterone than
others
um you know like I do is just look at
the bloodstreams and you can tell
um so
I forgot where I was going with this but
uh
women come into their own a lot earlier
than guys but it's still a 19 year old
girl is still pretty
shaky you know
a guy I don't really trust him a hundred
percent until about 30.
I'm gonna go even older yeah but he is
who he is at 30.
that yeah I'd go 35 but yeah
you're a woman you're [__] skeptical
of man as a guy but here's the thing if
you want if you want to wage war you
want to get into a fight you want to
have a bunch of [__] dudes that can
kick ass and get some [__] done you want
[__] late guys in their late teens
early 20s because they'll do what
they're told
and they're and they're not really
thinking they're not thinking about it
and they're disregard their own safety
they'll do all kinds of heroism and
[__] bravery and [__] yeah they'll do
all kind of stupid [__] yeah that's what
you need at that time that's what
they're built for that's why doing
stupid Nature has selected that in them
and you they need older guys to develop
it and to channel it and to and to
direct them you know what I mean to get
that for to put that energy to good use
and it
even the Romans knew it they knew
that that system no longer really there
it's all breaking down it'll come back
it'll come back Victor says puberty made
me gay
[Laughter]
yeah
puberty make a gay man gay
next Dimension media said I read a lot
of Stephen King books as a kid I read a
lot of Stephen King's it so did I
um he seemed to be obsessed with this
case yeah I think he was actually he
wrote a lot about it
um and uh Kitty Genovese he wrote about
which I kind of want to do a show about
that too that was that woman that got
murdered on that supposedly busy like
New York Street and everybody just like
stood around and watched her from the
window and didn't call anybody
um yes and I think it influenced several
books and movies like hardcore yeah
um Tyler the guy I'm 21 yet feel like I
have the energy and physique of a 60
year old
go on test oh that's funny
I mean you know uh so yeah so basically
yeah so they put her on the stand which
like I said was probably not uh probably
didn't help now the prosecution is
trying to paint her as what they called
a rebel in search of a cause like they
were basically saying well she's just
this poor little rich girl
um she decided she was gonna like rebel
against her parents
um and this was the way she chose to do
it she's gonna like hang out with these
[__] revolutionaries and do all this
crazy [__] and like live out this Bonnie
and Clyde fantasy of like being a
[__] you know bank robber or whatever
the [__] and um when she came out later
and said that
that when she'd been uh abducted by the
SLA that they'd actually kept her in
closet for a very long time like a
really small closet and uh that she was
raped multiple times by a couple of the
members uh the prosecution tried to
argue that she actually had consensual
sexual relationships with two of the men
which and they also brought up her
sexual history from prior to the
abduction which doesn't seem entirely
relevant yeah what you putting out with
these guys right so that's what I mean
about the judge because it's being like
biased against her a little bit it
seemed like this to me yeah that's like
that really shouldn't be admissible
because it's not it's not Jermaine to
the case like your sexual history prior
I think some of them [__] lsla guys
they just saw her and they go well she's
vulnerable [__] if I ask her to hit
she'll probably say yeah and she
probably she probably did
yeah I mean she basically said yeah
she's like that even if they weren't
I mean the implication was even if they
weren't like physically directly
threatening her at the time that she was
always under constant threat that it's
like if I didn't do what they wanted
they might be punished like I would be
killed or beaten or whatever
um you know she's like at the bank
robbery where she very famously said you
know up against the wall [__]
or whatever like on the tape they were
saying well I had to like appear really
enthusiastic about doing it because they
wanted it to look like she was in on it
because that you know
um you know and she's like if I wasn't
enthusiastic about it like I would have
gotten punished later that was the
argument that she was making
uh yeah I don't think that's what it was
I think it was something kind of like
some of the some of the things that I've
seen when I'm going through basic
training at [__] uh sad Hill
down in Fort Benning
he had some recruits that
got spooked by basic trading and we were
going through during wartime
and they started to check it out
but we had real drill sergeants back
then I mean [__] we were [__] scared
of them man drill started howl and
[__] I've looked him up he was the
[__] one of the best dudes ever
because I ended up [__] he ended up
coming to our unit in the 506 later on
it was like something out of the damn
movies man he was this big old [__]
black dude he was cool as [__] and we
were [__] terrified of him
and um
what what happens sometimes is you'd
have a guy and you could tell he didn't
want to be there and that he wanted to
fail he wanted to go home
but they would [__] double and triple
down on him and scare the [__] out of
this dude so bad that he would [__]
double down on the training and try to
man up and he would power through it and
all of a sudden he then enjoyed it kind
of like I don't know breaking someone in
to like a BDSM situation it might have
been a situation like that with her that
she didn't want to do it until they
pushed her so hard
she's like oh this is kind of fun
better than being in that damn [__]
closet
you know what I mean now I haven't got
power over the situation and they're
proven of me
I'm sure it's a lot more complicated
than because it's kind of Dynamics like
this are just like not it's not cut and
dried you know what I mean it's not
necessarily the fact that it's like oh
we had to be pointing a gun in her face
it could have been like some other kind
of power down because we'd have guys in
basic that they could have been [__]
kicked out at any minute week and all of
a sudden would man up and everybody in
the [__] platoon would like [__]
cheer them on and they were they were a
loser before and all of a sudden now
they're a hero
and [__] years later they're still in
service [__] totally different dudes
totally revealed men you know just
because that dude [__] made that one
decision to [__] it I'm going Kamikaze
and the Synergy of it
the wolf pack is a very [__]
seductive force in [__] the the life
of a young man when you're around a
bunch of other young men they can really
[__] influence and change you
hopefully for the better if it's a group
of good dudes you know what I mean
but no that's probably what happened
wolf pack got her
another thing too that happened what I
was saying before about the whole um
some of the other SLA members and the
prosecution arguing that she had
consensually like had a relationship
particularly with uh Willie Wolfe who
was one of the members of the SLA
um who she later accused of raping her
um one of the other members of the SLA
said oh well she still has this necklace
or this little kind of like it was like
a little Colombian artifact type of
thing like on a chain or whatever and
it's like she still had that in her
purse at the trial and so the
prosecution was making a big deal about
that like it's like oh why would you
keep a piece of jewelry that a rapist
gave you what'd she say
um she basically said she kept it
because she thought it was like um an
expensive artifact and it was worth
something or that she just liked art or
something which like I said sounds a
little
but you know I I don't know I think it's
more like Stockholm syndrome yeah like I
said might have been a mixture of stuff
maybe he put the [__] she was scared
of him but [__]
there was like missing people are
complicated yeah they're never just like
black maybe she's like you know what the
dude is pretty brave and he has these
other good qualities about him maybe
he's handsome so there's kind of that
Che Guevara kind of Panache you know you
don't know I hadn't seen it I mean the
thing about these dudes as [__] up as
these people were like they had some
ridiculous ideas and they did some
horrible [__] I mean when push came to
shove
um they died for what they believed in
they didn't like they didn't surrender
yeah they did so I guess that's
something so Mr 88 says I came into my
own as a middle schooler because of
absentee and abusive parents yeah
that'll happen uh I knew I wanted to
succeed and had to mature really fast to
make sure my circumstances didn't derail
me in part that's why I completely
skipped the late teen early 20s
behaviors like partying and drinking
yeah I did that you missed that well no
I didn't really do the partying and
drinking thing until I was in my 30s
yeah really I mean I drank and clubbed a
little bit like I was in my 20s but not
like crazy I did it because at the time
I was living in Sao Paulo Brazil it was
legal so I was in clubs at 15 16.
16 I think going to nightclubs legally
drinking
having fun and it was like a Duran Duran
video man you'd have loved it
and and it wasn't it wasn't like the
[__] immature [__] binge drinking
I did some of that that was better it
was better just to actually go to a club
like South American Club great had a
good time Tyler the guy said Tom's right
about the wolf pack thing I had a group
of friends that were complete douchebags
and it kind of rubbed off on me for a
while glad I cut ties with them yeah
that's why you know I hate to say but
your parents are probably right about
like the people that you hang out with
like it's like I don't like you hanging
out with those boys it's hormonal man
it's hormonal when I was on Trend man I
just wanted to rejoin the Wolfpack if I
saw bad [__] like I'm hanging
out with the [__] warlocks and [__]
for [__] bike night I'm like I'm
gonna hang out with these dudes you want
to hang out with [__] the biggest
most frightening most ugliest
[__] around you want you want
to hang out with them little guys that
look weak you just want to beat them up
I mean and it's you want them out of the
area so that's not a good time and that
that is just like Ultra gendered [__]
that's like out of the animal kingdom
yeah
but you know but the thing is this trend
isn't normal it's five times the power
of testosterone per CC and I was taking
a lot of it
for five months
because I thought I could because I was
under the effect of it yeah
I mean it took me about two months to
fully recover to normal
when you say about two months I don't
know it was a long time yeah too long Mr
88 says uh about male Synergy I have two
teen sons and remind them that the more
boys in a group the lower the expressed
IQ
but the higher the fun Factor we used to
burn down the [__] Woods out of
Mississippi and swing through [__]
Fire Man gasoline fire on a rope and
shoot each other with BB guns and then
shoot stuff with with your dad's
shotguns and [__] we had so much fun
ride around on [__] three wheelers
that was even before four wheelers and
then wreck and roll three-wheelers I
don't know how we survived it
I guess a few days a few probably didn't
I took a three-wheeler and [__] ran
it through a [__] gate that had been
opened and it was there was a turn there
and accidentally hit the gate and it was
a it was a wrought iron gate
and in between the [__] bars in the
gate was about three feet I hit it in
about 30 miles an hour and went flying
off the front of the [__]
three-wheeler and went in between those
bars clean in between those bars went
through the gate and landed on the
ground had I been a little fatter or had
I hit the gate just a little bit
to the right or the left that [__]
bar would have went right through my
head I don't know how the [__] I
survived that [__]
that was about 13 or 14 man damn just
stupid man stupid it was fun though kids
he's super cheap we used to [__] like
I said why do you think the Darwin
Awards books are like 99 dudes I was
down in Mississippi
on those three wheelers steal your dad's
three Windows let's run this [__] we're
trying to shoot bottle rockets had guys
in the back shooting bottle rockets at
each other oh man those are the days man
so uh so yeah all right
so basically what okay so Ben what Ben
was saying about the necklace or
whatever doesn't explain why she would
carry it if she thought it was some
important artifact she should have been
somewhere safe yeah I kind of thought
about that too that was the only thing
that kind of gave me pause like why
would she still have that like if I got
raped by some dude it's like I'm not
keeping anything that [__] gave
me for sure so it's like I don't know I
but like I said that doesn't negate the
Stockholm syndrome thing yeah because
she could have gotten all involved and
like fallen in love with the dude and
everything like that and it would have
been I think it was you know what I mean
I think it was more that than coercion
so I don't know if she was necessarily
raped I mean I guess she was raped in
the sense that yes she was abducted she
was the captive so she was the captive
so yeah I mean it's you know technically
it is rape no matter what happens
whether she said yes or not but um I
think it was the kind of situation where
you see out of those movies where a girl
ends up on a pirate ship
and the captain is cute as [__] it's
it's Johnny Depp
you know what I mean she's a captive but
hey you were talking about Johnny Depp
he's kind of [__] dashing it might
have been a situation like that maybe
it's rape yeah she's a captive yeah
I mean yeah let's not make any mistakes
yeah
yeah that's what any you know she's not
in her right mind yeah she's been taken
out of her environment
let me remind you people kidnapping is a
life sentence
most American states she was kidnapped
yeah she was taken out her apartment and
put it in the trunk of a car and when
you do that it puts a woman in a
psychological position of psychological
weakness to where you can take advantage
of her
she's more a lot more impressionable
especially at 19.
so it's rape well because she doesn't
want to get [__] killed yeah she
doesn't want to get killed yeah and uh
or whatever it is you're planning on
doing maybe these dudes are also kind of
impressive too but it doesn't it doesn't
matter they've taken her out of her
environment and put her in this
situation
so she's not really it's not her free
will
and she's also afraid of punishment so
no it's rape
so they're right yeah
because there's a Synergy to that
she's not truly consenting
yeah she didn't run away to join them
yeah I mean that would be a different
situation if she had actually of her own
free will said hey I'm gonna go Join the
Revolution yeah that's totally different
but she didn't do that right
she didn't do that so I think that
anything had happened after the
abduction was probably just like yep
they put her in the situation yeah they
put her there she didn't she's
she didn't choose it at the at the start
so um so yeah so like I said because uh
Patty Hearst had been put on the stand
and because apparently the jury was not
impressed with her defense uh she was
actually convicted uh she was convicted
in 1976 of bank robbery and using a
firearm during the commission of a
felony now she was actually given
uh the first sentence she was given was
uh 35 years God damn but then the judge
the original judge who didn't like her
uh he died so they got another judge in
there and he actually ended up giving
her seven years so she got a seven year
sentence she probably had to do three
and a half uh no she didn't uh just okay
you're jumping ahead they got it off
you're jumping in okay
um so actually she once she went to jail
she started having uh she had some
medical problems like she had a collapse
lung and some [__] like that and she had
to have surgery so she actually couldn't
testify at the other trials like from
the other SLA members like the harrises
and all of them
um now she was also because of security
because it was high profile they put her
in solitary confinement for a time
um her dad being rich like hired a bunch
of bodyguards and [__] like that
um she actually had like dead rats like
turning up in her bed like the other
prisoners didn't really like her at
which point they were just that's why he
hired the bodyguards and [__] like that
um now she actually uh her bail got
revoked in May 1978 she had a bunch of
appeals pending but they all failed she
was trying to go to the Supreme Court um
they turned her down
and basically what ended up happening
was that the harrises the couple that
had been with her for the you know on
that uh shoplifting thing they got
convicted on kidnapping and uh they got
eight years each so they served their
entire sentences and then got out
but around this time
uh speaking of the um Jim Jones case
representative Leo Ryan who was the guy
that was shot down there at uh at
Jonestown by the way uh prior to him
being shot obviously he was actually had
a petition
um to get Patty Hearst out of prison
um so he started doing that like I said
John Wayne was one of the guys that he
came out abdicating for saying it's like
especially because the Jonestown thing
had just happened and he's like you know
nobody believes she got brainwashed even
though you believe like 900 odd people
got brainwashed he talked about that
um so basically there was kind of like
an um a bunch of people kind of got
together and then there was like an open
letter like a big article that was
printed in the media that was addressed
to President Jimmy Carter saying like
please release her she was brainwashed
you know she didn't really you know she
was kind of forced to do what she was
doing so Jimmy Carter did actually
commute her Federal sentence
uh to the 22 months served so that's all
she ended up serving was 22 months and
then they let her out uh she was
actually let out eight months prior to
her first what would have been her first
parole hearing now there were conditions
to her release she was let out in
February of 1979.
um you know they she was under on
probation like they kept an eye on her
she couldn't like move around freely all
that kind of stuff
um however in 2001 she was actually uh
given a complete pardon by Bill Clinton
when he was leaving office uh so she had
all of her civil rights restored in
2001.
now uh after she was released from
prison in 1979 she actually married her
one of her bodyguards or her name was
Bernard Shaw not that one not the one
from CNN or whatever right yeah um it
was yeah it's a different guy uh that
was one of her bodyguards so she married
him which
I don't know I was watching One video
and she said that's a little weird that
she ended up marrying one of her
bodyguards probably not they were
together a lot that's yeah that's like I
didn't do each other and maybe he had a
good opinion over yeah because
I think I think she was not guilty I
think she was in a bad situation he felt
sorry for
maybe I can see how it could happen
yeah I could kind of see that she wasn't
in her right mind
this all [__] hinges on the fact
whether or not that abduction was real
if that abduction was staged no she was
guilty then yeah if that was a real
abduction then she wasn't guilty then
everything that happened after that was
it was suspense it was coercion and
brainwashing
and and if you [__] like I said go
listen to that audiobook rape of the
Mind
the person who's being brainwashed
depending on what kind of brainwashing
it is
feels guilty about who they are and they
feel that they're wrong
okay that's why that's how they get
changed
she felt guilty about coming from a rich
family
she was trying to atone for that
but what they did to her was [__]
criminal what are you talking about no
yeah it's still a criminal no matter if
you do it too yeah
and winterfella forever said she's not
she's not [__] guilty of what her
parents did if they did anything wrong
they probably didn't do anything wrong
they're just making money everybody does
it
they weren't taken advantage of
poor people per se
I mean if selling things to people is
taking advantage of poor people
you're not taking advantage of poor
people until you're [__] rigging the
political system that's when you [__]
take advantage of poor people
uh whatever I said undoubtedly was her
heiress status helped during her release
it was a regular Schmo or a black person
I doubt the justice system would have
been so kind yeah and uh I agree with
you on that and um yeah a lot of other
people would I agree with you also I'm
sure it really helped that she was a
very that she was a white woman an
attractive white woman from a very very
wealthy family
um you know had it been
some broke dick [__]
who wasn't good looking or was from a
minority or something like that
um I'm sure it wouldn't have gone I'm
sure there wouldn't have been like all
of this
you know father all about like oh please
let her out and all this other kind of
stuff so in that way
you know I hate to say but yeah if
you're a pretty white woman that's young
and stuff like that you're probably
gonna get away with some [__] that maybe
other people wouldn't get away with so
I'm and you know and she came from a
rich family too which always helps
um because those [__] get away
with everything so I'm sure that helps
but I'm not saying that I mean that
doesn't negate the fact that probably
um you know she didn't like I said she
didn't choose to join them I don't think
like Tom was saying like yes if the
kidnapping had been staged I don't think
it was it's a possibility sure but um
you know and I have seen some people
bring it up
um I don't think that's the case but if
that was the case then yeah that she'd
be completely on the hook and
responsible for everything that happens
subsequently was she if she was abducted
which I think she was
um then everything after that
is is a gray area because she didn't
choose to join them
um she didn't choose to go along with
any of that stuff and she just ended up
going along with it for whatever reason
whether it was Stockholm syndrome
whether they were forcing her whether
whatever so but you know the the fact of
the matter is if she was actually
abducted then yeah she didn't choose to
do any of that stuff
um so yeah so she got married they had a
couple kids
um one of the I think one her daughter
I think I read this somewhere is married
to Chris Hardwick I thought yeah it
sounds really who is Chris Hardwick did
he was on Talking Dead He's like that
funny guy okay yeah yeah yeah I'm pretty
sure I read that someplace but I don't
know if that's true
um she actually ended up publishing a
memoir uh later on like in the 2000s I
think like that and because of some [__]
that she said in there they were
actually thinking about bringing up some
new charges against her but they didn't
um but uh yeah so as I mentioned earlier
John her and John Waters were friends
and she was in several of his movies
um she was in crybaby I had forgotten
about that and uh it also had uh like a
Johnny Depp Johnny Depp and uh Tracy
Lawrence Tracy Lord Tracy Lords was in a
bunch of uh John her and John Waters
were friends too she was in a bunch of
his movies I remember Tracy Lord seeing
her on VHS before people knew she was
underage man [__] New Wave hookers
too I think it was oh man that's a
[__] badass flick I know have you
ever seen crybaby though no I've never
seen it you told me you'd never seen any
John Waters movies no I don't think I've
seen anything you probably like cry baby
that's a good one Trisha Lords was cute
Iggy Pops in it too she got cuter she
got older she was great and [__]
blade yeah she did a little bit part and
Blanche
um so funny she married just a normal
guy a bartender
who didn't know who she was
and then they found out he's like oh you
were a kid yeah and she started her new
life a new life after what a guy yeah
most dudes would be like ew
oh really oh that's you
I don't know well you were just a kid
yeah don't worry about it yeah but yeah
so uh so yeah Patty Hearst was like I
said in a bunch of John Waters movies he
was in crime but she was in crybaby She
Was a Serial Mom which is another great
one that's Kathleen Turner in it uh
pecker Cecil B demented which like I
said was actually sort of loosely based
on the actual Patty Hearst kidnapping
case
um but you know with the circumstances
changed a little bit
um and also a dirty shame also she was
in um biodome that Paulie Shore movie
yeah okay
um So eventually like I said now the SLA
members that weren't killed in The Siege
you know uh in 1975 were later captured
because like I said there wasn't there
was like [__] 12 of them you know
what I mean I think six of them were
killed in the fire fight
so the other ones were eventually got
convicted and went to prison
um some of them as I said served their
time and then got out and just became
normal productive members of society
like some of them were interviewed on
that uh documentary gorilla that I
watched earlier yeah
um there was one woman though named
Kathleen celaya I think is how you
pronounce her last name now she was
actually she didn't join until after the
shootout
um she joined it later holy [__] oh my
God damn we know you got a Harley bro we
know we we know you got got guys in here
that own Harleys
yeah making holidays but yeah so she
actually joined after that whole
shootout and then she was like [__]
putting bombs under police cars and all
this other kind of [__] they didn't
catch her until 1999. and then um she
actually got sentenced in 2002 and then
um it turned out too that like uh Bill
and Emily Harris William and Emily
Harris and another guy named Michael
Borton they actually got second degree
murder for killing that woman in the
bank robbery yeah uh so they got that so
they all did and I heard like some of
the testimony where they came out and
they were like you know man this were
really there's like there's nothing we
can say the you know bring her back to
life or anything like that it's like we
didn't mean for it to happen and we feel
really bad and all this other kind of
stuff so you know but yeah they still
went to prison so as far as I know
um Joseph Romero is I think the only one
that's still in prison he was one of the
ones that was convicted for the original
murder like um that the uh Marcus Foster
guy that they that they shot yeah
um I think he's still in prison but all
the other ones have done their prison
time and got out or they're dead so
there's pretty much that Patty Hearst is
still she does basically
um she does you know she does interviews
and [__] like that she's both basically
like a philanthropist nowadays you know
giving money to like
various causes I think she's real big on
like um AIDS Charities and stuff like
that but okay now the SLA members that
survived
what did they say about her
did they say that she was a member to
joined them did they know that she was a
captive what was the deal
from what I could determine
the ones that they the two that they
talk to on this documentary they seem to
make it think and I don't know this
might just be
um you know them covering their own ass
I'm not really sure
but they seem to think
that now it should be noted too that the
two guys that they talked to they were
not
um
privy to they weren't there like when
the abduction happened and I'm not
really sure they were on board with that
idea okay or they said that they weren't
they're like when it happened but they
thought it was kind of cool because
they're like oh we were getting all this
attention because suddenly everyone was
paying attention to us and we could say
whatever we wanted and they would do it
and so they were kind of getting like a
little bit of a power trip about it but
it did seem like they didn't say
anything about mistreating her they
didn't say anything about they basically
said that she seemed like
they were excited because she seemed
like she was going along with them and
like they like she was turning against
her parents and she was yeah that's what
I was saying it seemed like they
interpreted it as she was waking up to
the reality and she was like oh we we
like flipped her over to our cause it
seemed like that's what they were now
would they have had access to her during
the times where she was in the closet I
don't know or the so-called the rapes
supposedly I don't know they just didn't
mention that no no they didn't mention
it maybe they weren't there all the time
maybe they just yeah like I said this is
a very loose group it wasn't super
organized I didn't get that impression
it just seemed like a just a kind of
very loose group of people there's a
chance that they probably didn't really
know her story she's just some chick
they show up and she's there
they don't know where she came from
Jesus joined that made that may be the
situation
the dudes that would have not that
really did know would have died probably
yeah all the ones that were really yeah
in on the [__] like were yeah they were
killed in the shootout so we don't have
their testimony right we would know the
truth or maybe we would know the truth
because they would probably lie too
Winterfell forever said I don't know if
Jenny mentioned it earlier I did but
there is a good documentary about the
whole thing called gorilla yeah and it's
right here on YouTube you can watch it
for free
um I watched it earlier today like
before the show
um and Mr idiot we're talking we were
talking about um it probably helped her
one that she came from a super wealthy
family that always helps yeah be born
rich if you can manage it well you can
get you can afford a defense yeah well
and you've been poor she had a locked
her up and thrown away the key yeah and
also like I said and also
um be a cute white woman that that also
usually yeah but they throw those away
though too yeah yeah it's weird because
I kind of feel like cute white women if
you get like caught for a crime
it's probably in your advantage but like
if you're just walking around the street
like your serial killer shark it so it's
like it's kind of like one or the other
you know what I mean
um a lot of it has to do with your
record you know she could be a cute
white woman but if she's got [__]
three or four convictions on her and
she's got a bit no they're gonna [__]
lock your ass up yeah uh in a situation
like this bank robbery you're gonna do
time
cute white woman doesn't yeah you're
gonna do time well that's kind of the
thing is that even though I mean I think
it was only later like pressure from the
media and everything like that and you
know people that were kind of you know
advocating for her because the judge and
the jury in that case they were
perfectly willing to put her in prison
they didn't buy her story they didn't
buy the brainwashing thing they said no
she looked like she participated in that
[__] willingly and I kind of feel like I
know this maybe is weird to say but I
kind of feel like during the trial it's
almost like they forgot that she got
abducted yeah because they were
concentrating so much on you know how
much like um culpability she had for the
bank robbery and everything like that
I'm like but it's almost like they
almost kind of like swept that under the
carpet I was like well that being the
inciting incident is kind of like a big
deal it depends a lot with the cute
white woman factor I think it's mostly
stereotype it depends on what the crime
is
um I mean there was a cute white woman
bodybuilder just fantastic [__] plump
[__] body she's just hot big boobs
and [__] and she's making porn with her
husband
and the husband was a [__] free he's
a pervert
and he had her do a scene with a 10 year
old boy
uh
uh well that [__] leaked out
she got caught she's doing like 30 years
for it
so is he well yeah he's gonna say yeah
two women cute white women didn't help
there okay well I kind of feel like if
it's yeah if it's a kid is the victim
then yeah then all bats are up you gotta
it doesn't matter what you look like
yeah so this you know suckers
you got you can't go along with these
[__] stereotypes yeah and [__] and
like I said that dude who is [__] go
out killing those teenage girls his
girlfriend was a [__] cute white
woman
well that cute white woman [__]
killed two 16 year old girls after
making her [__] making them dig their
own Graves that's how [__] brutal
that [__] was
uh no
yeah I think that [__] got life
yeah so yeah Victor says cereal mom is
such a great movie it really is I mean
that's what you probably love that movie
it's like it's [__] fantastic it's
like a black comedy yeah um Winterfell
forever it said oh yeah I wanted to kind
of get into this too a little bit
so it's also worth mentioning that in
the group there were two other women and
as radical as they were they came from
pretty standard middle class backgrounds
yeah pretty much everybody other than
Donald defreeze who like I said was an
escaped convict I think I'm not entirely
sure I think he was in prison for
robbing a prostitute so it wasn't like
for murder or anything like that but he
escaped from prison but I think all the
other members were just like regular
metal middle class white people
um Winterfell forever said it seems to
me very unlikely that they would be okay
with harsh treatment or rape to another
woman and that is actually what the
prosecution argued at the trial when she
argued that the the two of the dudes had
raped her multiple times
um the prosecution argued well isn't
this group feminist
um and why would they allow that to
happen you know what I mean it's like
because I mean they had women that were
members and it's like that was kind of
part of their whole ideology and they
found it unlikely that they would allow
that to happen like I said I don't know
if that's the case or not but that's
what the prosecution are there's a bunch
of different kinds when you say rape you
have to understand each state has
different legal definitions they're
strong arm there's forcible and then
there's another called aggravated
and I think Strongarm is when
it's it's not forcible which is like by
force okay uh
um a strong arm was you you you've
weaseld your way into a woman you do
this you're gonna have sex with me or I
will tell your job this and that
right so you don't really have choices
right yeah yeah I mean you know right
so I um
I would say that this was [__] on par
with like
strong arm
yeah she had been captured
she went along with it
because she was afraid
so
probably but then there was probably
mixed emotions because there's Stockholm
syndrome going on yeah she might have
liked the guys too yeah but she didn't
have a choice
yeah and she had been captured she was
put in that position I mean we like I
said we do keep coming back to that it's
like she didn't actually just like run
there and say Hey I want to join the
revolutionaries the captive cannot
consent so therefore that this wrap
that's a wrap
like I said as long as we're positing
that the abduction was not staged which
like I said I don't have any reason to
believe it wasn't yeah that it was
staged because you're putting on a bunch
of psychological pressure she's
attractive
she's not in
sound judgment she's not in right-minded
sound judgment
you know so that that's the way a lot of
depending on the state that's the way a
state law would probably look at it
yeah that makes sense to me she's not
she's she doesn't have calm reasoning
and cool reflection yeah yeah but like I
said so she did get convicted at first
but she really only served like 22
months in prison uh and then she was let
out and like I said she was given a
complete part in in 2001.
by Bill Clinton when he was leaving that
was one of his pardons that he gave and
since then she seems to have had a
completely
normal life just having kids and doing
[__] that you do there's this song that
I like
this guy named Warren Zevon he's kind of
a [__] folk singer he did like and he
had a song called Roland the Headless
Thompson Gunner we used to get drunk in
Egypt that's such a good song yeah we
used to get drunk in Egypt Saint it was
about a Norwegian mercenary going down
to into Africa to help the band to him
and his boys
and he gets betrayed by a [__] CIA
agent that was in the group named
Vanowen who shot [__] Roland's head
off he was the best Thompson Gunner the
unit had ever seen
and from then on out you could see the
ghost of [__] Roland this headless
body strolling through the night mowing
down enemies
you can see it under the [__] muzzle
flash of his Thompson gun and the end of
the song one of the last person said the
song he kills is Patty Hearst
he said Patty Hearst heard the burst of
Roland Roland's Thompson Gunn and bought
it
but I have to say probably Warren was
probably wrong on that one he seemed to
be [__] uh I don't think he seemed to
be aware of [__] the pressures that a
little 19 year old girl could be put
under
she's BR she was brainwashed
it's funny because I had heard about the
Patty Hearst case like all through the
70s because like I said I was a kid in
the 70s so you kind of heard about it on
the news and stuff I didn't know a great
deal about it until this is y'all are
gonna laugh I looked it up in the 1980s
because
um there was a band called camper van
Beethoven and they had an album called
our beloved revolutionary sweetheart and
they had a song on there that was called
Tanya and it was about her
and I was reading about it and I said oh
I remember kind of like hearing about
that in the 70s so that's when I started
like looking it up because of that
camper van Beethoven song that was like
about her so that's like pretty funny so
she did so you can see like what a big
deal it was because it really kind of
seeped into the public Consciousness and
like somebody said too like Stephen King
like wrote about it a lot like he refers
to it a lot in a lot of his stories
which yeah I did remember that and the
Kitty genovesi case he seems like super
obsessed with that as well which like I
said I've been wanting to do a show
about that too but we haven't done that
yeah I got that wrong in that song they
wasn't helping to bet he's helping the
Congolese I think against the bad too
that's great song listen to it Roland
the Headless Thompson Gunner it is a
great drinking Soldier drinking song
about Mercenaries
yeah all right so it's quarter past ten
I really have to go to bed all right
yeah so I guess we're gonna wrap this
all up for the evening uh I feel like
this came out of goods this is an
interesting show I told you yeah I got
like really into this topic like over
the last few days while I was
researching it so hopefully you guys
enjoyed it and found it interesting
and so we will be back on Friday night
doing our Sidetrack show which is always
fun because we can talk about whatever
the [__] we want to I mean more than we
usually do
so hopefully you guys can join us for
that so thanks everybody for dropping by
this evening
oh my goodness and we'll see you again
on Friday night good night